SAFETY WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING. IN RESPONSE TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE A
MINUTE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING WISHING TO
PROVIDE COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TO TAKE TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOR.
AN ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FIVE
FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. BUT.
SIX FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE
SEVEN FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES SOON
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND FOR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE. THEN ZERO. FOR
SUPPORT AND WE'RE OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ME UNMUTE IT AND YOUR WILL BE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE. YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING FROM PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE FALL IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR YOU
HEAR FROM OU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS JUST
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED. FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS ARE
MUTED. WALKED EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN ITS CLOSE ASKED TO
SAY MANNER IT'S CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE HEARD
OR HEARD. WELL LET'S FIRST
BEGIN BY STATING THAT SB FIVE
TWO TWO BY SENATOR BORDERS HAS
BEEN FOOD POLL TODAY- FROM THE
AGENDA BY THE AUTHOR SO. WITH
CAPS SEVEN BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY THREE OR WHAT'S WRONG
CONSENT. BEFORE WE HEAR FROM
THE PRESENTATION LOTS OF STOPS
A QUORUM. CONSULTING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD REDFORD
HERE A CHOI BOGUE HERE THE
TURBO CARE COM LONGER SKINNER
YOUR SKINNER HERE WINNER BUT
WHEN WINNER PRESENT. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT ON LET'S
FIRST BEGIN. WITH A MOTION FOR
CONSENT CALENDARS- MOTION. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR SKINNER
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CONSENT CALENDAR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE A CHOI BOGUE HI
THE TROUBLE GUY COSMOGIRL.
SKINNER HI SKINNER I'D WIENER
WE ARE I. HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR CALMER WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NOW WE'RE IN A MOVE TO
OUR FIRST AUTHOR- I DON'T SEE
HIM YET SO WE'LL WAIT- ALL
HURTS FOR. A SEARCH BURKE WE
HAVE S. B. TWO SIX TWO. SENATOR
HERTZBERG WHEN YOU'RE READY
SENATOR. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
I STAND BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY 2% THIS MEASURE ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND MY JOINT AUTHORS
YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER
SKINNER AND TOGETHER WITH. MR
BONTA FOR THE OTHER HOUSE- IT'S
BEEN PART OF THIS PROCESS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. TOMORROW WE'LL
GET ASIAN AND THIS GOVERNMENT.
IS TO ENSURE A FAIR PROCESS
THAT PEOPLE ARE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT. THAT
VICTIMS ARE PROTECTED. AND TO
CONTINUE TO LEARN AND TO GROW
AND GET BETTER AS CIRCUMSTANCES
CHANGE. IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
I EMBARKED UPON THIS SAID AFTER
WORKING A NUMBER OF MEASURES
THAT CAME OUT OF THE FERGUSON
REPORT AND THE INJUSTICES IN
FERGUSON. AND IT HAD TO DO WITH
THE BAIL SYSTEM. IN THE BILL
SYSTEM IS A PLACE WHERE FOLKS
ARE CHARGED WITH A CRIME BUT
HAVE THERE HAS NOT BEEN THE- A
JURY TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THEY'RE GUILTY OR INNOCENT. AND
SO WE AS A SOCIETY TRY TO
MEASURE AND BALANCE OUT THE
ISSUE OF. TAKE IN TREATING
PEOPLE FAIRLY TO MAKE SURE THEY
CHECK SHOW UP TO COURT. IN THE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T
COMMIT FURTHER CRIMES IF IT'S A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASE OR SOME
PARTICULAR AREA AND WE HAVE
BEEN. DEALING WITH THIS IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY SUCCESSFUL WITH
RESPECT TO THIS ISSUE OF BAIL.
SO IN BARKING ON THIS JOURNEY.
OUR FOCUS WAS REALLY WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED ABOUT HOW UNJUST AND
UNFAIR AND INEFFECTIVE THE
CURRENT BAIL SYSTEM HAS BEEN
TURNS PEOPLE'S LIVES UPSIDE
DOWN DOESN'T MAKE THE COMMUNITY
SAFER DOESN'T RETURN PEOPLE TO
COURT QUICKER HI WE HAVE THE
DATE ON THAT WHICH I'LL TALK
ABOUT. STAGGERING FACES WERE
PEOPLE ARE CHARGED WITH A CRIME
INTO THE CURRENT BAIL SYSTEM
AVERAGE BAILING CALIFORNIA'S
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. YOUR
SHOULD BE TO A BAIL AGENT YOU
DON'T HAVE YOUR OWN FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU GOTTA PUT
FIVE GRAND YOU DON'T GET IT
BACK. HUGELY ON JUST ASPECTS OF
THE SYSTEM UNFAIR AND- MOST
IMPORTANTLY NOT EFFECTIVE IN
PROVIDING. JUSTICE AND SAFETY
FOR. OUR COMMUNITIES THE
CURRENT BAIL SYSTEM DOESN'T
EVEN RESULT AS I SAY FROM A Q.
SHOWING UP A RECORD RECENT
RESEARCH FROM THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES AND CONCLUDED THAT
SIX POINT SIX OF CALIFORNIA
DEFENDANTS HAVE MULTIPLE
FAILURES TO APPEAR WELL THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. IS TWO POINT
NINE MEETING OF THE BAIL SYSTEM
AS EXISTING DOESN'T EVEN SOLVE
THE PROBLEM THAT SEEKS TO SOLVE
IT HAS EXTRAORDINARY
CONSEQUENCES SO IN LOOKING FOR
SOLUTIONS AND EXAMINING THIS ON
A NATIONAL LEVEL WE WORKED YOU
KNOW MAKE IT SHORT ON THIS PART
WITH THE CHIEF JUSTICE WHO PUT
TOGETHER A WORKING GROUP. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE MEASURE
SOME OF WHOM FOLKS HERE ON THIS
COMMITTEE WORD AUTHORS AND
JOINT AUTHORS AND CO AUTHORS
OF. AND WE WAITED FOR THE
SUPREME COURT. TO ACT AND THEY
BASICALLY TO MUCH TO MY
SURPRISE SUGGESTED A SYSTEM
BASED OUT OF PRE TRIAL
DETENTION BASED UPON A SERRANO
CASE OF THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT THAT SAYS AS LONG
AS YOU HAVE A PRE TRIAL
DETENTION SYSTEM YOU DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE BAIL. SO THE PROPOSAL
ULTIMATELY IN SB TEN WHICH THIS
BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH AS
ALL GET TO WAS REPLACING THE
WITH THE CURRENT SYSTEM WITH
THE BAIL SYSTEM WHICH WORKS
SUPPORTING IN THIS MEASURE WITH
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SYSTEM
OF ALGORITHMS AND A HUGE
BUREAUCRATIC INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH FORM. THE FOUNDATION OF
THE OPPOSITION. SO THAT MAKES
WAS PASSED. AND THE ARGUMENTS
JUST TO MAKE IT CLEAR AS TO WHY-
THAT WERE MADE WITH RESPECT TO
THE SEVEN COMPANIES THAT PUT UP
THE MILLION DOLLARS TO PUSH TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEIR BAIL
INDUSTRY BUSINESS THE SHIRT
ACCOMPANIES. THE ARGUMENTS
WARNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
SYSTEM IS FAIR AND JUST OR
EFFECTIVE THE ARGUMENTS WERE
ABOUT ALGORITHMS THE ARGUMENTS
THAT WERE MADE THAT THESE
COMPUTER BASED SYSTEMS I'M
READING FROM THE OFFICIAL VOTER
GUIDE. HOW THE GOODS TO MAKE
IMPORTANT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS COMPUTER MODELS MAY BE
GOOD FOR RECOMMENDING SONGS AND
MOVIES BUT USING THESE
PROFILING MESSAGE TO DECIDE WHO
GETS RELEASED FROM JAIL AND WHO
GETS A LOAN HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
HER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ALICE
HUFFMAN PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA'S
CONFERENCE OF THE N. DOUBLE ACP
FATHERS CREATE TALKED ABOUT
BUREAUCRACY. NOBODY NOBODY IN
TRYING TO DEFEAT REFORM OF THE
BILL SYSTEM SAID THAT THE BILL
SYSTEM WORK. NOBODY SAID THAT
IT WAS JUST. THEY ALL JUST SAID.
ALGORITHMS BUREAUCRACY MORE
SPENDING TAXES THOSE ARE THE
ARGUMENTS AND SO THE ISSUE THAT
INFORMS THE FIRE BOB MARLEY
COSTS THAT ARE FIGHTING FOR
THIS ISSUE IS JUSTICE JUSTICE
MEASURED BY PUBLIC SAFETY BUT
JUSTICE AND THAT IS NOT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE LAST ELECTION.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS BILL
WITH SENATOR SKINNER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA DOES NOT RELY ON
THE PROCHE OF WHAT WE'VE TAKEN
BEFORE IT BASICALLY REPLACES IT
DOESN'T REPLACE WHICH WAS DONE
AT THE SUGGESTION OF THE
WORKING GROUP BY THE CHIEF
JUSTICE. BUT IT WORKS ON THE
EXISTING SYSTEM UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION A BAIL AND MAKES
IT BETTER FAIRER MORE JUST. SO
EACH THE FIRST POINT IS THAT
THIS BILL IS COMPLETELY IN
LARGE MEASURE ACTION A
COMPLETELY IN LARGE MEASURE
BASED UPON. THE D. ZERO BAIL
ORDER BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
MEANING THAT THE JUDGES SCRUB
THIS REPORTS THE GALLERY AND%
THE LIKE AND WE'RE BASICALLY
CODIFYING THAT ZERO BAIL.
MEASURE THAT WAS VETTED BY THE
COURTS DOES FOUR THINGS FIRST.
IT LEVELS THE PRE TRIAL PLAYING
FIELD BY SETTING BAIL AT ZERO
DOLLARS. FOR MOST MISDEMEANORS
AND LOW LEVEL FELONIES EXACTLY
HOW THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT
AN EMERGENCY ORDER OF APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY SECOND. IT
ENSURES THAT THE ACCUSED DID
NOT ASSUME ANY COSTS OF COURT
IMPOSED PRETRIAL RELEASE
CONDITIONS ANOTHER ISSUE
COMPLETELY UNFAIR ABOUT THE
RICH VERSUS THE POOR. IF YOU'RE
POOR YOU'RE STUCK IN JAIL YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY THAT'S
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO IS ONE
OF THE CORE JUSTICE ELEMENTS
HERE THREE. REQUIRES BILL
COMPANIES TO REFORM THE
PREMIUMS THEY RECEIVE FROM
PEOPLE ARRESTED BUT ARE
CHARGED. WITH THEIR CASES
DISMISSED IT AVOIDS THIS
UNBELIEVABLE PREDATORY LENDING
COULD YOU IMAGINE. IF YOU WANT
HAD A LOAN AGAINST YOUR HOUSE
FOR FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU
TO PAY A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
FREE HOPE SORRY THE LOAN NEVER
WENT THROUGH BUT WE GET TO KEEP
THE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. I
GIVE YOU A HUNDRED EXAMPLES OF
JUST HOW. LEE UNFAIR THAT IS
AND FOURTH IT ENSURES THAT THE
ACCUSED TO NOT REMAIN IN
CUSTODY SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY BAIL. ABOUT
THE SUPREME COURT HAS JUST
HEARD IN JANUARY VERY IMPORTANT
CASE CALLED IN RE HUMPHRIES. IT
DEALS WITH THE ABILITY OF A POP
UP- SOMEONE WHO'S ACCUSED
ABILITY TO PAY A DALE. THAT
CASE I'M TOLD WE SPOKE WITH A
LAWYER YESTERDAY WHO ARGUED THE
CASE THAT DECISION MAY COME
DOWN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS SO
RATHER THAN IN THE LANGUAGE
THIS MEASURE MAKE AN ASSUMPTION
WE SIMPLY REFERENCE THE
HUMPHRIES CASE AS TO. GUIDED BY
THAT. SECOND FROM THE APRIL TO
THE SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
WHEN THE ZERO BILL ORDER WAS IN
PLACE THE BOTTOM LINE IS ALL OF
THE DATA PP I SEE WE'VE GOT
SOME OPTIONS SOME LETTERS WERE
PEOPLE TELL ONE STORY OR
ANOTHER STORY ABOUT SOMEBODY
WHO GOT OUT OF JAIL AND CAUSED
ANOTHER CRIME OR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE BUT THE EALITY IS
THAT PROPERTY CRIMES HAVE
DECREASED DURING THAT TIME
FRAME SECOND VIOLENT CRIMES
HAVE REMAINED CONSISTENT
THERE'S NO FUN FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF THIS
POLICY THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS
PEOPLE ARE TREATED WITH JUSTICE
AND DIGNITY THAT GO OVER THEIR
FAMILIES. THEY CAN DEAL WITH
THE ISSUES THEY CAN HIRE A
LAWYER THEY CAN KEEP THEIR JOB
THEY DON'T HAVE ALL THE OTHER
CONSEQUENCES THEIR LIVES ARE
NOT COPPING A PLEA YOUR CASE TO
GET A JAIL BECAUSE OUR LIFE IS
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN. SO IT IS
JUST EXTRAORDINARY. THAT WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IS HOW EFFECTIVE
THE ZERO BALANCE AND IN FACT.
THIRTY ONE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STILLHAVE
THE ZERO BILL SYSTEM. AND IT
STILL WORKS YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
EXAMPLES I'M SURE. OF SOMEBODY
GO TO JAIL THERE WAS SOME
EXAMPLES AND ONE OF THE LETTER
OF THIS PERSON HERE AND THAT
PERSON THERE. ALWAYS IS THE
CASE. WHAT DO WE MAKE PUBLIC
POLICY BASED UPON THE ISOLATED
EXAMPLE IN ONE INSTANCE TO
ANOTHER BASED UPON THE
OPERATION ORDER WE LOOK AT THE
LARGE BODY OF DATA. IN TERMS OF
WHAT IMPACT THERE IS TO SOCIETY.
WHAT WE KNOW. IS THAT. IN
TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY THIS IS SO
CRAZY AND SO SIMPLE. IF YOU TAX
TO SOMEBODY. PEOPLE ARE NOT
SHOWING UP FOR COURTBECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO THE BAHAMAS
ARE GOING TO SOME PLACE. THAT
DOESN'T HAVE EXTRADITION.
THEY'RE BUSY. THIRD GOT WORK
THEIR KIDS GOT SICK. THEY LOST
THEIR PAPERWORK WHO KNOWS.
SHOULD THE EIGHTY BE SUBJECT TO
SUCH IMPOSITIONS OF THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM AT THEIR
LIBERTY BECAUSE OF THAT. IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. A MODEL
WHICH INCLUDES TEXTING. 95% OF
PRETRIAL APPEARANCES RATES FOR
DEFENDANTS. AND THE- THREE
THIRTY POINT MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE FIRST SIX MONTHS SAVE MONEY
GETS APPEARANCES IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BETWEEN APRIL. TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN MARCH TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN DEFENDANTS
RELEASED ON OWN RECOGNIZANCE OR
SUPERVISOR CARDS SINCE MEANING
THAT THEY'RE GETTING THESE
TEXTS OR WHATEVER. AVOID
REARREST FOR NO OFFENSE THE
SERVICE MEMBERS. 99% OF THE
TIME THERE IS NO BETTER DATA
TREATING WITH PEOPLE WITH
DIGNITY AND FAIRNESS ON THE ONE
HAND AND ACHIEVING THE SYSTEMS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN
GOVERNMENT THIRTY ONE
JURISDICTIONS HAVE KEPT THE
SYSTEMS BECAUSE IT'S WORKING.
SO. I AM HERE TODAY TO CONTINUE
FIGHT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH FOR MANY YEARS. I
WILL NOT GIVE UP THIS FIGHT.
BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT WHAT IS
RIGHT AND WHAT IS FAIR AND WHAT
WORKS WHAT WORKS WHAT IMPACTS
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN A VERY
SIGNIFICANT WAY. THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ZERO BAIL AND BAIL. IS
A POOR PEOPLE STAY IN JAIL
UNDER THE BAIL SYSTEM. UNDER
THE BILL SYSTEM IF YOU GOT THE
MONEY WHETHER YOU'RE THROUGH
WITH ALL RISK OR NOT YOU YOU'RE
OUT. DO WE WANT A SYSTEM BASED
UPON THE- WE WANT OUR SYSTEM TO
DETERMINE STUDENT GOVERNMENT
CERTAINLY WHICH PEOPLE CAN HIRE
BETTER LAWYERS. THEY CAN LIVE
IN BETTER COMMUNITIES BREATHE
BETTER AIR FLY IN PRIVATE JETS
NO COST. FAIR NUMBER HAS A
RIGHT TO DO THAT. BUT WHAT THEY
DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO DO SAID
THEIR GOVERNMENT MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR THEM THAT THE
GOVERNMENT MAKES A DECISION. AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT YOU ARE FREE
OR NOT WHAT GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
DO IS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
WITH THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO
IN EVERY INSTANCE IS TO MAKE
SURE. ALL WHICH- EVERY INSTANCE
POSSIBLE PEOPLE'S LIBERTY IS
NOT DETAINED FOR IRRATIONAL AND
WRONG REASONS AND THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE. SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS THIS MEASURE WE HAVE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT THE FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE. CENTER SKINNER NINE.
BUT WE'VE DONE IT. IN A WAY.
THAT DOES NOT LOOK AT THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WERE OUTLINED.
IN THE PREVIOUS MEASURE THAT.
WE DEALT WITH A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO. WELL WE'RE WORKING WITHIN
EXISTING. AND WERE BEING
INFORMED BY WHAT THE SUPREME
COURT'S HOPEFULLY WILL DO IN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS. LAST YEAR I
BOUGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG REPRESENTATION NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT I SEE YOU
HAVE A PRINCIPAL WITNESS BY THE
NAME OF ESTEBAN UNIONS ARE
CORRECT YES. I CAN I JUST SAY
ONE THING SIR I APOLOGIZE I
FAILED TO MENTION THIS. IN THE
PASSION OF MY MOMENT- BUT THE
ADDITIONAL COALITION PARTNERS
ON THIS MEMBERS. OFTEN HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH US SINCE DAY
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY THE
ENTER RECIDIVISM COALITION. AND
OUR NEW PARTNERS ARE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
ESSIE JUSTICE WHO'S WHO'S IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AT ALL
OF COASTAL COALITION OF FOLKS
THAT WE'RE HOPING TO BRING ON
TO BRING TOGETHER. IT WITH
RESPECT TO THIS ISSUE SO THANK
YOU SIR I APOLOGIZE LET THANKS
FOR ALLOWING ME THAT THAT BUT
THE FIRST WITNESSES A STEP ON
UNIONS. FROM THE OBSERVER SAID
COLA. MISS NOONAN WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO SIX TWO. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS AT FUNDING AS I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING FOR THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION ALSO
KNOWN AS A R. C. A. R. HE WORKS
TO END MASS INCARCERATION IN
CALIFORNIA. TO ENSURE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE HEALTHY
AND WHOLE EMPOWERS FORMERLY AND
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
TO THRIVE BY PROVIDING A
SUPPORT NETWORK COMPREHENSIVE
REENTRY SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADVOCATE A
POLICY CHANGE. THERE ARE
GRASSROOTS POLICY ADVOCACY WE
ARE DEDICATED TO TRANSFORMING
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO
THAT IT IS MORE JUST AND
EQUITABLE FOR ALL PEOPLE. HAS
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO REFORM
CALIFORNIA'S PRETRIAL SYSTEM-
OVER THE COURSE OF FOUR YEARS
BECAUSE WE HAVE WE TRULY
BELIEVE IN EQUITY FAIRNESS
ACCOUNTABILITY. BUT ALSO AN
ECONOMIC JUSTICE I WANT TO
GROUND US IN A STORY OF AN A.
R. C. MEMBER WHO SADLY IS
UNABLE TO BE WITH US TODAY.
RIGHT BEFORE KOBE GRAND RAPIDS
IN CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTED BUT
YOU'RE A BELL SCHEDULE FOR
PEOPLE BEING CHARGED WITH LOWER
LEVEL OFFENSES. AND A R. C.
MEMBER HAVE BEEN. INTERNALLY
STRUGGLING WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES AND WAS ARRESTED AND
CHARGED WITH VANDALISM. IT BELL
AS WELL BEYOND WHAT YOU COULD
AFFORD A TRUTH BE TOLD THIS
YOUNG MAN WAS IN DIRE NEED OF
HELP AND SUPPORT OF SERVICES
NOT COUNTY JAIL. A WEEK LATER
HE WAS MURDERED IN COUNTY JAIL.
WHAT WHAT HE REALLY NEEDED
AGAIN WITH SUPPORT OF SERVICES
AND THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
BACKED OUT OF THERE SHE- I
OFTENTIMES. THESE LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES OR CRIMES OF
DESPERATION AND OUTCRY IF YOU
WILL. NOT ONE THAT SIGNALS THE
FUTURE LIFE OF CRIME BUT ONE
THAT SIGNALS THEIR BASIC NEEDS
ARE NOT BEING MET- COUNTY JAIL
COULD NOT ONLY BE TRAUMATIZING
WITHIN ITSELF. BUT IT CAN
EXACERBATE ALREADY UNDERLYING
TRAUMAS IN CONDITIONS IT'S NOT
A PLACE OF HEALING
REHABILITATION OR MATURATION.
COUNTY JAIL IS A PLACE WHERE
YOU ARE QUICKLY STRIPPED OF
YOUR DIGNITY AND CONFIDENCE
IT'S A NATURAL DEPRESSION REAL
BUT DESPAIR AND FEAR. WHAT LIES
AHEAD HERE YOUR EMPLOYER WOULD
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO SHOW UP FOR WORK. YOUR
CHILDREN WILL END UP IN THE
SYSTEM BECAUSE YOU CAN'T BAIL
OUT HERE THAT YOU MAY BE FORCED
INTO A PLEA BARGAIN BECAUSE YOU
KNOW OUR SYSTEM HAS STOCK STOCK
YEAH BOB AGAINST YOU OR WORSE.
DEATH YOUR AVAILABLE WAS WITH
THE MY OR BASED ON THE MEDIA
RISK SENATE. I CALLED AND I TEN
AND WASN'T BACK BETWEEN A AND
JUNE TWENTY. ONE IN THE STORE
WE SAW SICK. REDUCTION COUNTY
JAIL POPULATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHEN WE SAW NO REAL
SPIKE IN CRIME FOR THE- BEING
CRIME FOR THOSE OFFENSES WHICH-
WERE ELIGIBLE UNDER TERREL
BELL. YES YOU SEE DATA SHOWED A
STATEWIDE INCREASE OF 30%
COUNTY JAIL POPULATION BETWEEN
FEBRUARY AND MARCH AND MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA'S EUROPE BELL
SCHEDULE WAS LIFTED IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY ONE COUNTY
DOESN'T SENATOR MENTIONED. I'M
STILL. I SOME FORMS ZERO BUT
INTO. I KNOW THIRTY ONE K. THAT
I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT-
REPRESENT 80% OF CAL. PROP WHY
WOULD THEY DO THAT IF THEY WILL
IT MAY THAT THERE CA BE AN
BURTON AND WITH CRIME WELL
THERE WASN'T A THE SENATOR. AND
A REPORT PUBLISHED ON OCT THAT
THE PEOPLE I. C. PROVED THAT
THE FRENCH AND- ELIGIBLE ZERO.
OTHERWISE NO SPECTER CRIME AND
FURTHER MORE THERE WAS ANALYSIS
BY K. YOU OUT WHICH CHANNEL BY
THEIR COUNTY ALL OF. CENTRO CON
COSTA SONOMA. AND SANTA CLARA
AND IT FOUND THAT IN THE TIME
CAL HAD INSTITUTED A DURABLE
POLICY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE
PER 22% OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ALLOWED TO BAIL OUT FOR
FREE. WERE REARRESTED. DURING
THAT WANTED WEEKS WHICH CIGNA.
LOWER THAN CAL. ARE RATE AND
CONVICTION RIGHT. FREE TRIAL
JUDGES IN THE REPORT THAT SUPER
A PER INCOME IN THE COMING
WHILE STANDING TRIAL ABOUT TEN
PER. OF THE COST OF KEEPING
THEM IN. WITH THE SHOWING THAT
ABOUT MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
RELEASED PRE TRIAL DO NOT
REOFFEND AND THAT VERY LITTLE
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ENSURE THAT
THEY SHOW UP TO COURT ON TIME.
BOTH THESE COST HUMAN AND
FINANCIAL. ARE JUSTIFIBLE AND
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE- THE ENTIRE RECIDIVISM
COALITION ALONG WITH. OUR
COALITION OF SUPPORTERS AND CO
SPONSORS ARE ABOUT IN SUPPORT
SB TWO SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO SIX TWO DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES WHO- TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SHEEN NINE
COMING FORWARD WILL MOVE NOW TO
ROOM. TWO ZERO FOUR ZERO. ARE
THERE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO SIXTY TWO AND ROOMS
TWENTY FORTY. SENA NEAR THANK
YOU NOW WILL MOVE HER WITNESSES
WHO ARE TESTIFYING VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO SIX TWO. THEY WILL
BEGIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE NOW WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS. THANK
YOU MODERATE A COULD YOU GIVE
ME THE NUMBER OF- CALLS WE HAVE
BEEN Q. IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
ELEVEN THANK YOU. CAN CONTINUE.
BY FORTY THREE. WARNING MISTER
CHAIR CHRIS RESPONSES POLICY
ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WITHOUT A VEHICLE
SPONSOR. YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE THIRTY NINE. YEAH I'M NOT A-
DOCTOR OR. BY ONE THIRTY NINE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO REPEAT THAT
WASN'T VERY AUDIBLE. IT DARNELL
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. BY. SEVENTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED SENATORS
ANTI DIMARTINO WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE
CROWD CO SPONSOR OF SB TWO
SIXTY TWO AND ALSO ON THE APPLE
MIXTURE IN CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU Q. MIX WITH
US. LINE ONE FIFTY SIX. OKAY
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING DOOR ROSE BIGELOW
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
ONE HAND. ON BEHALF OF SMART
JUST OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. FIND ONE FIFTY FOUR.
HUNDRED DOLLAR ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AT THE CO SPONSOR OF
THE DELAWARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE THIRTEEN. DEREK BUYERS
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE. THIRTY SEVEN. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING MARCO GEORGE
ALSO FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. ONE FORTY
SEVEN. HELLO AND GOOD MORNING
JENNIFER MALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE FORTY NINE
NINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FINANCIAL SUPPORT I AM A
CITIZEN AND FATHER OF SIX AND I
SUPPORT. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
AND THAT IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU I ACTALLY
CHECKED ONE MORE TIME BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO WITH THIS IN
OPPOSITION. THE FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL
MOVE TO WITH THIS OPPOSITION WE
HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IDENTIFIED WILL GIVE THEM TWO
MINUTESOF PEACE WE HAD A NINA
SOLANO BALL SOMEONE AND WE HAVE
MARKS SKIP MAN SCEC MAN I'M
SORRY SILVA IF MISSPELLED
SOMEONE IS PREPARED WE WILL
START WITH HER. YES THANK YOU-
THANK YOU TO- THANK YOU THE
COMMISSION TO HEARING TODAY-
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED
RESPECTIVELY OF HER AB TWO
SIXTY. PHOTO CRITICAL AS
SUPPORTER OF THOUGHTFUL WILL A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AB SIX
TEACHING. TWO SIX TWO IS NOT
THAT- ZERO YOUR VARIANTS WITH A
MISERABLE FAILURE AND NOT WHY
IT BEEN RESCINDED IT AB SIX.
TWO SIX TWO. SIX ALLOW DEAR
OKAY WHAT THEY CALL QUOTE LOW
LEVEL UNDER BUT WHAT ISN'T
MEMBERS AS UNDER. THAT LOW
LEVEL CALIBER COULD TO
CONNECTING THERE'S A CRIME UP
GUIDED BY HELD HIM AND TRY.
THESE ARE SOME VERY DANGEROUS
THAT WOULD BE ON THE DAY. FOR
PROBABILITY WHERE THEY ARE IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD. THE STATE
POINT OF TARA POSITION TO THE
AB SIX TWO IS THAT- IN CAL
BECAUSE- IT IS INHERENT PICTURE.
HAVE THE SAME. AS THE ACCUSED
AND THAT IS THE RIGHT TO A
SPEEDY. AND RIVERO BAILED BIG.
IF IN FAVOR TO. WHICH THAT
MEANS THE BIG THING COURT IS
DELAYED UNTIL THE PER IS EITHER
RE ARREST. ON THE FTA OR
OFFENDS ON A CRIME AGAIN
HARMING ANOTHER. AND THAT BOB
BACK TO COURT. BECAUSE ALL ARE
TO THE SAME MIGHT HAVE TO HAVE
THIS TRIAL AND THE ZERO BAIL
SYSTEM WILL THAT TESTED THE
THEN THE RIGHT. THIRD AND I
THINK MOST OF IS THAT HAVE TO
THE OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST OF THE- PAGE ATTEMPTED TO
DEMOLISH AND- DISTINGUISH AND
EXTINGUISH IT HEARING TO. AND
THE VOTE APPEAR CLEARLY SET THE
THEY WANT A OFF SYSTEM AND CAL.
TABLE IN THE OF THE OF THE BILL
SYSTEM. THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY
HELPS IN THE CAR JUSTICE. AND
THAT WOULD DEFEATED THEREFORE
VOTERS HAS. HERE THAT OUR BAIL
SYSTEM IN WHAT THEY WERE TO
STAY PLACE. IT MAY NEED MONICA
BUT REDUCE IT TO A- GAIL SAYS.
ABSOLUTELY AGAIN WHAT THE BILL.
AND LASTLY ON THE TWO ZERO
SUPPORT FOR NOBODY SHOULD BE IN.
JUST SIMPLY OF MONEY IS. BUT WE
WAS MUCH REMEMBER THAT ARE K.
PENAL CODE- HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
H. OFFICER. WHO IS ENTRUSTED
WITH RUBIO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AFTER OF. THE BAIL SYSTEM TO
ALL ALL FROM THE REALLY. FOR
MINOR. REASONS REASONS THAT IS
AND HAS IN OUR P. CODE. AND OUR
VERY LAST POINT IS THAT YOUR
BILLS YOU CAN DENY THE VICTIM
THERE RIGHT INHERENT IN ARTICLE
TWENTY EIGHT OF OUR ON. WHICH
IS THE RIGHT TO BE HEARD AT THE
BAIL. SO POOR IS REALLY P. WITH.
ANY TYPE OF HEARING IT IS
INHERENTLY. AND THEN VIOLATION
OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIA CRIME VICTIMS. HAVE
A RIGHT TO BE HEARD ON THEIR
PERSONAL SAFETY ISSUES. AGAIN
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE MESS THE
COMPUTERS HUMAN TRAFFICKERS
YELLED IF YOU TO WRAP YOUR
COMMITTED NINE VILLAGE. RIGHT
TO BE HEARD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO VOTE THANK YOU MOVING ON
TO OUR NETWORK. MARC SEGMENT.
GOOD MORE SOUTHERN OF MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARK FACT ON WHAT
AMERICAN CASUALLY AND OF SO. A.
B. C. I. HAVE NO POSSESS FOR
SECTION BILLBOARD LIKE TO SPEAK
ABOUT SEX THREE OF THE BILL
WELL THIS IS LOCATED IN
PERSONAL KERR IT HAS CHARGED
WITH COMMISSION AND SHOULD
HEARD BY SENATE IN CHARGE
AFFECT YOUR BANK ARE STATED IN
THE NOW THE BAIL AGENT CONTRACT
WITH THE COME ADDITION BAIL
BONDS ESSENTIALLY ASSURED. RAIL
SYSTEM OFTEN. OR DO A LOT OF
THE- SECTOR TO ENSURE. A
PROVIDE A MEANS FOR COUNTY.
HOLE IN THE ABOUT THE- FAILED
TO PAY. YES WHAT DOES THE LAW
FOR REBATE TO BILLS PROVIDED.
BUT THERE'S A STEP BETWEEN A
BALL. WE ADDED TO KICKBACK
WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL CREATE.
THIS BILL BY LATE THE-
PRINCIPLE THE SHARKS. CHARGES
BASED ON SIMPLE. PROMISE OF.
OLDER BY THEN SURE PRODUCT
BARKER SURE ON THE END OF. ON
AS ONE OF THE- EMERALD COVER
THE POWER OF YOUR CHURCH BACK
AS WELL AS OUR- ON THE- ALL
CHILDREN. QUITE THERE'S NO WI
FI GIVEN. THAT'S WHAT COULD.
THE IN A ONE CAR BUT THE LAW
BAR NUMBERS. OF CONCEPT ALLOWS
THE CHURCH. READ THE REST OF MY
BROADER OF A POLICYHOLDER. AND
IT ALMOST LIKE WITH THE PLAN
WOULD PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
FOR THESE REASONS A PROJECT A
REQUEST SECTION THREE D. WITH
FROM THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NOW LET'S MOVE TO OUR- AND-
BOB. ON THE PHONE WHILE I'M
WELL FIRST IN THE ROOM DO WE
HAVE ANY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- S. B.
TWO SIX TWO. CHIGNON LET'S MOVE
NOW TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWO SIX TWO. SHE NINE NOW
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
Q. AND OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
SIX TWO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE DO- AND AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY TWO ONE THREE TWO TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER STEPHANIE WHITE MUCH OF
THEIR APOLOGIES FOR NOT MAKING
IT THROUGH ON THE- AND- CALL TO
A- OUR SUPPORT FOR AMNESTY TO.
TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. WITNESSES NINE WHAT ON.
WHY ONE THIRTY SEVEN. YES GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
MY NAME IS PAUL POWER ON BEHALF
OF ALL PRO BAIL BY I WE ARE TO
THE BALLOT CURRENTLY. WOULD
REQUEST A THIS ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THIS. ONE ONE TWO
TWO. GOOD MORNING MR TO I FOUND
COMMITTEE MAY CAP VENTURA
GOLDEN STATE BELLAGE THAT THE
STRONG TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
SH SH. WHY. ONE FORTY SIX. BY
WHAT NINE OF THE. EST THE
COUPON ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING AS A- AND WE OPPOSE
BASED ON THE BILL A
CONSTITUTIONALITY THANK YOU.
BLIND ONE SIXTY. YES LARRY
MOORE'S CALIFORNIA JUST
ATTORNEY ASSOCIATION WITH GREAT
RESPECT TO SENATOR HERTZBERG IN
REGRETFUL OPPOSITION. FIND. ONE
SIXTY SIX. I'M OFTEN SEEM
POLICY ADVISER FOR CALIFORNIA
SAFETY AND JUSTICE I COULDN'T
GET THROUGH ON THE LINE FOR
STRONG SUPPORT AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO PARDON
ME WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON WHO
JUST SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF BAIL HOTLINE BAIL
BONDS IN OPPOSITION. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU ONE MORE TIME MISTER
MODERATOR JUST- CHECK ALONG TO
MORE TIME JUST TO BE SAFE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY MORE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THIS
IS THE FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE. Q. WE'RE GOING TO BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
THE COMMITTEE SENATORS CAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU- SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
BRINGING US THIS BILL OF COURSE
I AM PART OF THE EFFORT TO
BRING THIS BILL AS A PRINCIPAL
AUTHOR- NINE AUTHOR JOINT
AUTHORS CORRECT- YOU ADDRESSED
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS THE
ISSUE AROUND- ON THIS NOTION OF
IT THERE SOME OF OUR OPPOSITION
SPOKE ABOUT IT LIKE THAT THE
YOU KNOW THIS. TO REDESIGN THIS
WOULD BE ON DOING THIS NOTION
OF IT AS AN INSURANCE POLICY SO
I WILL LET YOU AN ADDRESS THAT
IN JUST A MOMENT BUT I WANT TO
MAKE COMMENTS BEFORE YOU DO- WE
HAVE A BASIC FUNDAMENTAL FACT
THAT. BECAUSE OF OUR THE WAY
OUR CURRENT MONEY BAIL SYSTEM
IS DESIGNED. PEOPLE WITH MONEY
GET OUT OF JAIL AND PEOPLE
WITHOUT DUE NORTH. AND THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR. AND THAT
WEALTH TEST MEANS THAT SOME
PEOPLE AND AGAIN EVEN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS BASED ON
INNOCENCE UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
BUT THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE A-
DOLLARS AMOUNT THEN THAT
DETERMINES WHETHER YOU SIT IN
JAIL PRIOR TO A TRIAL. IS IN
EFFECT LIKE A GUILTY SENTENCE
BECAUSE THE IMPACT OF SITTING
IN JAIL MEANS THAT YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO WORK THUS YOU MAY EVEN
LOSE YOUR JOB AS A RESULT MOST
LIKELY YES. THE END YOU ARE
ALSO NOT BEING ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO YOUR HOUSEHOLD
EXPENSES WHICH PUTS YOUR FAMILY
IN A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION
OR IF YOU'RE A- SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL. IT CAN PUT YOU IN
ARREARS INTO AND GET YOU INTO
DEBT. IT PUT YOU TAKES YOU AWAY
FROM YOUR FAMILY. AND IT CAN
CREATE A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU GET BEHIND ON
CAR PAYMENT OR A RENT PAYMENT
YOU CAN LOSE YOUR ABILITY TO
YOUR VEHICLE YOU'RE AT WHERE
YOU LIVE. NOW WHAT KIND OF
JUSTICE IS THAT IT IS NOT
JUSTICE IN TERMS OF THE MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS TRYING TO BE-
THE OTHER THING WE HAVE BEEN IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND
I'D SAY MUCH MORE SO. IN THE
LAST NINE MONTHS. LOOKING MORE
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH A RACIAL
LENS AS TO HOW TO CHESTER
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICIES BUT-
ALL KINDS OF POLICIES HOUSING
POLICIES YOU NAME IMPACT
DIFFERENT PEOPLE. AND IF WE
TAKE JUST THE BLACK COMMUNITY
SO JUST BLACK CALIFORNIANS. AND
WE LOOKED AT. HOW THE SYSTEM
IMPACTS. BLACK CALIFORNIANS ARE
DETAINED DETAINED AT A RATE
FIVE TIMES HIGHER THAN WHAT
CALIFORNIANS BLACK DEFENDANTS
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE RELEASED
ON THEIR OWN RECOGNIZANCE THAN
WHITE DEFENDANTS AND BLACK
DEFENDANTS AGES EIGHTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY NINE RECEIVE
HIGHER BAIL AMOUNTS THAN ANY
OTHER GROUP AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT. AND YOU ALSO LOOK AT
WEALTH COMPARISONS OF BLACK
AMERICANS TO WHITE AMERICANS
WERE CALIFORNIANS SPECIFICALLY.
BLACK AMERICANS HAVE BLACK
CALIFORNIANS HAVE FAR LESS
WEALTH COMPARATIVELY SO THEN
THEY ARE PUT FURTHER IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCE OF NOT BEING ABLE
TO AFFORD BAIL NOW FOR SOME
PEOPLE THEY USE A HOME. IN
ORDER TO PUT UP THE SECURITY
FOR BILL BUT WE SAW WITH IN
GENERAL THERE'S LESS
HOMEOWNERSHIP BY BLACK
CALIFORNIANS IN WITH THE LAST
GREAT RECESSION IT DROPPED EVEN
FURTHER. AND HOPEFULLY THIS
PANDEMIC INDUCED RECESSION WILL
NOT CAUSE A FURTHER DROP IN
BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT ONCE
ONE'S ABILITY TO RETAIN THEIR
HOME SHOULD NOT. P. BUT
THREATENED BY A UNFAIR MONEY
BAIL SYSTEM SO I AM VERY PROUD
TO BE PART OF THE COALITION
THAT AND A- JOINT AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL BUT SENATOR ERTZBERG
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THIS
INSURANCE NOTION. YEAH YOU KNOW
THAT'S A FUNNY ARGUMENT WITH A
BILL LAST YEAR ON THAT ISSUE
BUT- CALIFORNIA WE DO THIS ALL
THE TIME DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU'RE DEMOCRAT REPUBLICAN
CONSERVATIVE LIBERAL DOESN'T
MATTER. GOVERNMENT SAYS THAT
THERE'S SOME BEHAVIOR THAT'S
UNFAIR YOU CAN'T CHARGE
SOMEBODY 2000% INTEREST TODAY.
ITS USERS WE GO MAKE THOSE
AGAINST PUBLIC POLICY AND SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU'VE GOT THIS
INDUSTRY THIS IS WILSHIRE
INDUSTRY AND COMES UP WITH SOME
LEGAL DEFINITION. OF THIS A
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT CASE
RIGHT NOW IN THE BAY AREA IN
YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS SENATOR
THAT LOOKS AT THE ISSUE OF
PRICE FIXING THIS IS A BIG.
THAT SAYS WELL. IT'S 10% WELL
GREAT IF YOU GO BY CAR YOU GO
BUY SOMETHING EVERYBODY GETS
THE SAME PRICE THAT'S PRICE
FIXING I THINK THEY'RE GOING
BIG TROUBLE I THINK YOU LOSE
BIG. I THINK THAT THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THEY HAVE ON THE CLOCK IS
TICKING AWAY BECAUSE THE WHOLE
SYSTEM IS BASED UPON.
UNFAIRNESS TO THE PUBLIC. AT
EVERY LEVEL AND SO THE ISSUE
ABOUT BEING AN INSURANCE POLICY
AND WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
ARGUE. ARE JUST LEGAL FICTIONS
THE REALITY IS GOVERNMENT ALL
THE TIME ENGAGED IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION. ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN
CHARGE WHAT THE CONDITIONS ARE
WHAT TYPE OF DISCLOSURES HAVE
TO BE AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS
AND WE ALL SUPPORT THOSE ALMOST
A UNANIMOUS BASIS. TO THOSE
ARGUMENTS FAIL AND I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IN TROUBLE ON
THE ISSUE PRICE FIXING. AND THE
DAY IS COMING SOON. SOONER
OTOBO. WHERE DO WE GO SENATE
HERTZBERG. ONE BEGIN BY
THANKING THE TURF YOUR PARTY TO
SPEAK AND THAT WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR
TIRELESS EFFORTS FOR MONEY
UNDERSTAND YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
A VERY LONG TIME IN AN EFFORT
TO FIND EIGHTY A FAIR AND
BALANCED SOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE
AND I AM AN ABSOLUTE CREAM IN
WITH YOU IN THE FACT THAT.
THERE IS DEFINITELY- A PROBLEM
WITH WITH OUR SYSTEM IT THERE
REALLY IS FUNDAMENTALLY THERE
IS A PROBLEM AND I COMPLETELY
ACKNOWLEDGE IT AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS THAT SENATOR
SKINNER HAS- MENTIONED EARLIER
TODAY- WE DO HAVE A CULTURE
THAT UNFORTUNATELY. IS NOT.
VERY VERY CONDUCIVE TO THE
NOTION OF INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY AND THAT GOES BOTH ON IN
A SOCIAL MEDIA IT GOES TO OUR
NEWS RESOURCES YOU JUST
CULTURALLY WHERE WE- FIND
OURSELVES IN IS VERY VERY
UNFORTUNATE ESPECIALLY IN A
COUNTRY LIKE OURS- WHICH I'M
VERY GRATEFUL TO BE A PART OF-
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS
AND THAT I WANTED TO. TO
MENTION ON HERE AND- LET ME
BEGIN BY STATING THAT- I DO IN
THE STATE AND WANT TO NOTE
THAT- CALIFORNIA VOTERS
REJECTED. THE NO BAIL- SYSTEM.
AT WITH RISK ASSESSMENTS
IMPOSED ON BY S. B. TEN WITH A
FIFTY SIX POINT FOUR PERCENT-
BUT THE MAJORITY VOTE IN IN
NOVEMBER. THIRD TWENTY TWENTY.
AND I DO IN ITS CURIOUS BECAUSE
I WAS JUST SENT A FAX FROM MY
DISTRICT IN WHICH THE MAJORITY
OF MY DISTRICT ACTUALLY-
REJECTED THAT FILLED AS WELL-
SO THE PROBLEM IT WAS REJECTED-
FEDERAL IT WAS 62% IS WHAT I
THINK I SAW QUITE A BIT SO I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON THEIR BEHALF
AND THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE- WITH THE ISSUES AND ONE
OF ON. SOME OF THESE LEADERS
FIND MY NOTES HERE- THE
EXCLUSIONS ARE VERY SPECIFIC IT
BADLY BUT A LOT OF A TROUBLING
OFFENSES INCLUDING THE FACT
THAT- IT EXCLUDES I BELIEVE-
CHILD ABUSE AND ELDER ABUSE
JUST TO NAME A COUPLE- THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF THEM THAT I THAT
I FOUND THAT THEY WERE BEING-
EXCLUDED ON HERE AND I WANTED
TO I UNDERSTAND YOUR- YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT. ISSUE OF
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU. WHAT'S
THE WORD I'M LOOKING FOR HOW DO
YOU COME INTO AGREEMENT WITH
SOME OF THE EXCLUSIONS THAT ARE
VERY SPECIFIC TO THIS BILL-
LATE SUCH AS LABOR RELATED. TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CHILD ABUSE
HATE CRIMES AND WEAPON
OFFENCES- THAT FALL INTO IT.
TELL IT BOTH OF THEM WITH
RESPECT TO THE ISSUE ABOUT WHAT
WAS ON THE BALLOT BUT THIS
MEASURE S. B. TWO SIXTY TWO IS
NOT S. B. TEN PERIOD AND OF
ISSUE. RAISE THE ISSUE THAT THE
ARGUMENTS THAT. WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THAT THE GUT
VOTERS ATTENTION IF YOU SAW THE
ADVERTISEMENTS ON TELEVISION
THE LIKE ALL HAD TO DO WITH THE
ISSUE O AN ALGORITHM. SO WHAT
DIDN'T GO TO THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH DEAL
WITH IN THIS MEASURE WHICH IS
JUSTICE AND CORRECTING THE
SYSTEM THAT I APPRECIATE YOU
NOTICE. YOU MENTIONED IS UNFAIR
IT GOES TO WHAT THE APPROACH
WAS SO IT CLEARLY IS NOT THIS
IS JUST A GOOD FAITH. EFFORT TO
FIX THIS UNBELIEVABLY
EXTRAORDINARY PROBLEM AND NOT
TO OVERTURN THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS IN ANY RESPECT TO. WITH
RESPECT TO THE ADDITION OF THE
IT D. EXCLUSIONS FIRST OF ALL
IT WAS MENTIONED BY. THE
WITNESS FROM CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
EXCLUDED NOT THE CASE IT IS.
INCLUDED NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO-
REGARD THE CHEAP JUDGE YOU. IF
TO- ON IN RE WEB WE WAS A BY
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN CASE HELD
THE TRIAL COURTS DO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE REASONABLE
CONDITIONS. RELATING TO PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PERSONS RELEASED ON
BAIL. THAT SOMETIMES RELEASING
ON ZERO BILL COULD BE SUBJECT
TO REASONABLE RELEASE
CONDITIONS. BUT UNDER THIS
MEASURE THEY WOULD NOT THE
DEFENDANT WOULD NOT INCUR COSTS
FOR SUCH CONDITIONS SO THE
REALITY IS CERTAINLY JUDGE
COULD MAKE THOSE DETERMINATIONS
THAT HAS BEEN NOT LOST UNDER
THE- CONSTITUTION THAT THERE'S
BEEN ARGUED IT'S JUST BEEN
MISREPRESENTED. AND THERE IS
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT SO WE'RE
WORKING WITHIN THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE. OF WHAT COUNTRIES
BAIL. WE'RE ASKING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO COME UP WITH THE
BAIL SCHEDULE WE'RE WAITING TO
SEE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT DOES BECAUSE NO MATTER
WHAT OUR OPINION HERE IS.
THAT'S GOING TO CONTROL THE
DECISION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEONE HAS TO PAY TO GET OUT
OR NOT. AND WE'LL SEE WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. RIGHT AND WE ARE
TRYING TO WHO. WERE RELYING ON
WHAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL DID
THEY GAVE US A GREAT DEAL OF
THOUGHT. AND HAS A RECORD FROM
APRIL TO SEPTEMBER. AND THIRTY
ONE COUNTIES HAVE CONTINUED
THIS SO THIS IS NOT JUST
INVENTING SOMETHING AT A PIE IN
THE SKY. BUT WHATEVER SO VERY
THOUGHTFUL DELIBERATIVE
ENDEAVOR. GROUNDED IN VERY
SMART PEOPLE AND GROUNDED IN
WAITING FOR THE SUPREME COURT'S
ACTION WHATEVER THAT MIGHT BE.
I THINK IT HELPS IF I COULD
ANSWER THE QUESTION. THOSE
QUESTIONS IT DOES AND I'M
REALLY CURIOUS TO SEE HOW THE
COURT. PROCEEDS AND I'D BE
LOOKING FORWARD TO DOING
THERE'S A LOT OF A CERTAIN SICK
YEAH I VERY VERY MUCH. AND THEN
THERE WAS THE IT IS WITH THE-
IN THE IN THIS IS A THAT SAYS
THAT. EACH WE PAY OFFENDERS AS
THE SAME AS FIRST TIME OF. IS
THAT CORRECT. IT'S A- PUSH AND
ANSWER- SO WITHIN THIS BILL-
THERE'S AN THERE'S- A- BUT THE
WORD I'M LOOKING FOR A GIFT TO
MOTIONS THINK IF YOU'RE S. IS
THE IF IS A CAME A MISDEMEANOR
SAME RULES APPLY THAT MEANS THE
JUDGE STILL HAS UNDER IN RE WEB
IF THERE SOME CIRCLE THAT THEY
WANT ALL A COULD. BUT THE IDEA
IS I MEAN WHAT'S THE FUNDING
LOOK THE PEOPLE HERE. HAVE
HUGELY BROKEN HEARTS KERR
THINGS HAVE TO THE LIVES AND I
HAVE EXT. COMPASSION FOR THEM
AND THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
CHALLENGING DEALING WITH FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IS TO CREATE A
SYSTEM IT'S JUST THE FOLKS AT
THE ENTER RECIDIVISM COALITION
WILL TELL YOU ABOUT SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN IN JAIL FOR A DAY
AND WAS MURDERED BECAUSE THEY
WERE STUCK IN JAIL AND GOT BEAT
UP IN THAT MURDER THERE'S THIS
HORRIBLE HORRIBLE HORRIBLE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT JUST AND NO
ONE CAN DO ANYTHING BUT JUST BE
IMPACTED BY THE QUESTION IS AS
A SOCIETY AS A SENATOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WHAT'S
THE POLICY GIVEN THE EVIDENCE
THAT YOU HAVETHAT YOU WANT TO
ENGAGE IN. AND WHAT WE WANNA DO
IS HAVE A SOCIETY WHERE THE
SIZE OF YOUR WALLET DOESN'T
DETERMINE YOUR LIBERTY AND
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FLEXIBILITY
IN THE SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE
JUSTICE AND VICTIMS ARE TAKEN
CARE OF NOTHING AFFECTS THE
VICTIMS RIGHTS LAWS THAT WAS
MENTIONED ON THIS WE IN THE
OPPOSITION ARE GONNA AND
ADDRESS THAT MY CLOTHES DOESN'T
ADDRESS IT ALL VICTIMS HAVE
EVERY RIGHT THEY'VE ALWAYS HAD
NOTHING CHANGES THAT LAW
WHATSOEVER. AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THE BEST THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO FIX THAT THAT
INFORMS THE ADVOCATES ON THE
ONE HAND AND THE JUDGES ON THE
OTHER WHO DEAL WITH THE SYSTEM
EVERY. SINGLE DAY. IN FIVE I'M
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW YOU KERN
WORKING THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS. IN THE- SAZH OF. WITH
REGARDS TO THIS BY. THE MARKET
PER WILL TO ATTRACT MEAN I JUST
SAW THAT THE- AND HEARD ON THE
FOR I JUST GO IT OVER THE
WEEKEND THE- BEFORE THE PICTURE
OF COURSE WITH. TO MAKE. SAND
AND I KNOW IT I TRY DRESS FOR I
KNOW I AM. EVERYBODY ME WE
ALWAYS A- BUT WILL IF A WAY TO
SO THE DOESN'T COME. THE
UNDERLYING VALUE. DEAL WITH IT.
YEAH I AM VERY SO. HOW WE
CONSIDER A IDEA I'M I NEW TO
THIS ISSUE I'M YOU TO THE
SENATE PERIOD BUT I DO HAVE A
WITH THREE HOW WEAK WHETHER OR
NOT. THESE FEE IN THERE FOR NOW
CALL TO PAY WHO ARE IN A CAN BE
TAKEN AT THE BAR. MOTION THE
TICKET BUT MEAN MANY MEAN THAT
THE BECOME RESPONSE WHO IS
PRICED CANCERS. FOR THE
FINANCIAL- HARD THAT INNOCENT
PEOPLE FACE ONCE THEY'RE PROVEN
INNOCENT. SURE YOU MEAN TO TELL
ME THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD PICK
UP THE TAB FOR THE CONSEQUENCE
OF THE LIVES I UNDERSTAND.
YOURSELF ACTION THAT I MEAN THE
PROBLEM IS YOU FOR BETWEEN NOW
MORE PUT YOUR RIGHT I IF YOU'RE
IN IF YOU CAN YOU'RE DID
SOMETHING YOU PAY THE PRICE I
EVERYBODY AGREES THAT. BUT
WHICH TO DEAL WITH HERE IS HOW
DO YOU CREATE A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE SYSTEM IF YOU'RE
SUGGESTING THAT THE PROSECUTORS
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICES. PAY FOR THE COST OF
THE IMPOSITION ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES BECAUSE THEY'VE KEPT HIM
IN JAIL. I SUSPECT THAT- THE
DISAGREED. OFFICE SERVICES.
WOULD STRONG HIM. TO THE
PROTEGER. I COULD BE WRONG BUT
I WOULD THINK SO. AND I WOULD
ALSO THINK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCING OF CHALLENGER THAT
TO. DETERMINING THOSE COSTS.
AND I WOULD HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT BECAUSE- YOU THE WHOLE
PURPOSE HERE IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- BALANCE OUT PUBLIC
SAFETY WITH. PEOPLE'S LIBERTY
AND FAIRNESS. I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH YOU AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX
PERHAPS IN MAKING SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN PEOPLE ARE ARRESTED
THERE TRULY ARE. THERE'S
REASONS FOR THAT FOR THAT
ARREST AND IF THEY'RE GOING TO
BE PLACED IN. AN AND
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THEY HAVE
THEIR FINANCIAL. ECONOMIC.
OPPORTUNITIES IN PERIL. THEN
YOU KNOW. WE HAVE TO FIND TO
SEE WHO'S GOING TO BE LIABLE
FOR THAT- AND PROTECTING THEM
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
PROTECTED SO JUST THINKING
OUTSIDE THE BOX. I'M I'M NOT
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL AT
THIS TIME BECAUSE I'M CURIOUS
TO SEE WHAT THE COURT DOES. AND
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE WHAT YOU
DO. IN IN RELATIONSHIPS WITH.
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT.
THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO HAVE SOMETHING THAT
IS FOR A BALANCE IN THAT
REFLECTS- YOU KNOW THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AS WELL AS THE
SAFETY. OF THE PUBLIC. IF YOU.
THANK YOU ARM SENATOR IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT SHE STILL
THAT APPEARANCES HAVE FOR THOSE
FOLKS WHO WERE AFFORDED NO BAIL
WAS UP AM I CORRECT 99% OF THE
COURT APPEARANCES. BUT THE
OPPOSITION STATED THAT- FAILURE
TO APPEAR HAS INCREASED VERSUS
ARE DECREASING- HOW CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT AND WHERE THE
DIFFERENCES ARE AND- WHAT YOU
STATED IN WHAT THE OPPOSITION
BELIEVES THAT THEY'RE JUST
WRONG. THEY'RE JUST WRONG
PERIOD IT'S CERTAINLY
CONVENIENT FOR THEM TO SAY SO
BUT LET ME JUST GIVE YOU SOME
ADDITIONAL DATA FOR OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE HAD THE
SITUATION GOING ON LET'S LOOK
AT NEW JERSEY OKAY. NEW JERSEY
JAIL POPULATION DECLINED BY 47%
IN FOUR YEARS AFTER PASSING
REFORM IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CRIMES HAVE FALLEN
STATEWIDE IN ALL CATEGORIES
EXPRESSLY VIOLENT CRIME WHICH
IS DOWN EIGHTEEN POINT 4% WE
ARREST RATES BEFORE AND AFTER
BILL REFORM REMAIN THE SAME
COURT APPEARANCES RATES ARE AT
NINETY PERCENT. AND THE FACT
OKAY NEXT LET'S LOOK AT NEW
YORK TERMS OF ANOTHER EXAMPLE
GET NOT PERFECT EXAMPLES BUT
THE GENERAL UNDERLYING
ARCHITECTURE THE QUESTION
YOU'RE ASKING THE NEW YORK IT
THE ENACTED REFORMATORY TWENTY
JOB POPULATION STATEWIDE
DECREASED BY 30% CRIME DID NOT
GO UP. OKAY SIMILARLY THE
KENTUCKY IN KENTUCKY THAT I
WENT AND VISITED YOU KNOW 25%
FOR THE DATA COULD MISCHIEF OF
SHOWS THAT MORE PRE TRIAL
RELEASES DOES NOT COMPROMISE
PUBLIC SAFETY MORE THAN THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE CITED
AND RELEASED IN TWENTY TWENTY.
COMPARED TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN REARREST
FOR PEOPLE RELEASED PRETRIAL
HAVE REMAINED STABLE IN COURT
APPEARANCE CONTINUE TO STAY
HIGH AT 93% TO GIVE YOU MORE
EXAMPLES THEY TELL YOU THAT PP
I SEE SAID THE SAME THING. WE
SAID WE DID THE ANALYSIS WE
HAVE THE ONE OF THE GREAT
THINGS OF HAVING THAT THAT THAT
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FROM APRIL TO
SEPTEMBER IS WE HAVE SOME DATA
TO SHOW. WHETHER WHAT THE
ARGUMENTS ARE VERSUS WHAT THE
REALITY IS AND THAT'S WHY WE
CHOSE TO PROCEED. WITH THIS
MEASURE SENATOR. SKINNER MY SO
AND BY ANOTHER WHO FOR. HER
PART THIS AND YOU KNOW.
INCLUDING HR. AND SENATOR CO
AUTHORS. HAVE CHOSEN THIS IT
WILL TAKEN LIGHTLY IT IS GOOD
FOR EFFORT DEAL WITH A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM THAT'S A
1000% DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
HAPPENED. WITH RESPECT TO THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WERE OFFERED.
AND REPRESENTED AS THEY WERE
REPRESENTED- IN IN THAT IN THE-
BALLOT BALLOT BALLOT MEASURE IN
NOVEMBER. THANK YOU NINE ONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THIS ISSUE I THINK- ISSUE
SHOWN INSIDE- EXTRAORDINARY.
JORDAN BALES DO NOT. THREE THAT
DECREASE CRIME IN KIND OF WAY
TO ONLY GREW. THE DEBTORS
BECAUSE IF THING WE- THOSE WHO
WEALTHY- IT BERMAN ELEMENTARY
WHO HAVE BACKED TO GAS WILL
ALWAYS BE ABLE TO POST BAIL AND
IT'S TO WORKING. WILL WHO FIND
THEM- IN OR IN LIKE SAY FOR.
LONG PERIODS OF- BETWEEN A RED.
AND TRIAL SO I THINK THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND- I
LOOK FORWARD TO IT MOVING
FORWARD. I AM SEEKING A MOST-
WE HAVE A TO PASS. I REFERRED
TO APPROPRIATE. THERE ARE MOVE-BILL. EXPECTED TO MAKE WHEN
SLIGHT COMMENT. ON ON THIS- ON
THE SYNOLOGY THE INSURANCE
CONCEPT- IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE FOR SOMEONE IN
YOUR FAMILY AND THAT FAMILY
MEMBER PASSES AWAY PRIOR TO THE
AGE AT WHICH THE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE WOULD- WOULD BE IN
EFFECT. THE FAMILY IS
REIMBURSED MOST INSURANCE THEY
REIMBURSE AND SIMILAR ON A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER- INSURANCE
POLICY- NOT SO WITH THE BILL
NOT SO- BUT I'M OF THE BILL. IF
YOU SEARCH FOR WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE THE EIGHT MOSTLY ARGUES
MAKING CLOSE- I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
AND WAS TO QUESTIONS NUMBER ONE
IS I ALSO WANT TO THINK OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION HAS BEEN. A STALWART IN
THIS ISSUE VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY
AND CONTINUES TO BE SO. ARM IN
AND I THINK ALL THE ARGUMENTS
THAT WERE MADE MENTIONED HERE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY TWO THINGS
ONE. THAT THAT YOU KNOW AGAIN
IT'S PART OF OUR OBLIGATION
GOVERNMENT. AND THAT IS THE
COST TO TAXPAYERS WE SAW THIRTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN SIX
MONTHS EVEN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THOSE NUMBERS I READ TO YOU IN
TERMS OF JAIL POPULATIONS ALTER
PEOPLE'S LIVES UPSIDE DOWN TO
COST TAXPAYERS BETWEEN A
HUNDRED AND TEN. AND TWO AND
FIFTEEN DOLLARS A DAY. I MEAN
IT'S JUST A SYSTEM. IN ALL THE
IF YOU WANT AND READ MY UTIS
DICTIONARY. IS THE TERM I USE A
LOCKING CARP FOR THE JEWISH
PEOPLE IN THE IN THE AUDIENCE
IT MEANS HAVING A HOLE IN YOUR
HEAD IT IT IS. EVERY LEVEL.
IT'S DUMBER THAN ABOUT OVER HOW.
IN SO. ASIDE ITS IMPACT AND THE
COST WE DON'T OF THE TALK IN
TERMS OF TAX PAYERS AND TO DO
WITH WITH SENATOR- FOLKS- BOB-
COM ABOUT LAWN FOR BUT I WILL
HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH THEM I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE WITH
SENATOR SKINNER AND A SIMILAR.
BUT BUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
OTHER ADVOCATES OF THE DAY THE
IT'S ABOUT MONEY IN THE
ARGUMENTS OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
THIS THEY CHANGE EVERY DAY
WHOEVER YOU THAT ALIGN YOURSELF
WITH IT'S ABOUT THE MONEY AND I
DON'T BLAME THE THEIR BUSINESS
OKAY THIRTY BUSINESS FINE THEIR
JOB IS TO PROTECT THE BUSINESS
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT BUT
THEIR BUSINESS HAS A HUGE
HORRIBLE HORRIBLE IMPACT ON
SOCIETY. AND SO THEY WOULD
THEY'LL COME UP WITH WHATEVER
ARGUMENT THEY NEED TO COME UP
WITH TO BE ABLE TO WIN THE DAY
AND YOU KNOW I'M CURIOUS TO
HEAR AND HAVE A CHANCE TO TALK
TO THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS
TO SEE WHAT THEY THINK IN THAT
REGARD YOU KNOW I KNOW THERE
WAS ONE BIT GAVE THREE EXAMPLES
OF COULD HAPPEN BUT THOSE THREE
EXAMPLES OF THREE EXAMPLES ON
THE OTHER SIDE SHOVEL WILL TALK
TO THEM AND SEE WHAT THEY'VE
GOT TO SAY. BUT I THE BIG ISSUE
IS AS YOU THINK ABOUT THIS.
CENTRO TROUBLED THE- DISABLED
BECAUSE I. TO SERVE. BUT I KNOW.
BACK IN THE DAY- GIVE THIS IS A
CHANNEL IS. BUT A RIGHTEOUS
ONE. AND I'VE THE PATH WE'VE
TAKEN THIS MESS. GIVEN THE
HUMPHREY CASE WAITING FOR THAT
TO SAY WHICH MY CHANGE OF. AND
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT. TO TRY TO
DEAL WITH THIS EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPACTFUL PROBLEM ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES. THAT THIS MEASURE IN THE
PERCENT PAYROLL MEASURE IN THE
OTHER HOUSE. I THINK WHICH
ACHIEVES A PROPER BALANCE AND
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING THE COURTS
TO EACH COURT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BILL SCHEDULES OF ONE
COUNTY WHICH SUMS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND X. COUNTY THE SAME
COST AS A MILLION BECAUSE OF
WHATEVER THEIR EXPERIENCES. AND
ALLOW THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
BECAUSE OF COURSE ONE OF THE
ARGUMENTS WITH THE SITE IS
LET'S GET STATEWIDE BILL
SCHEDULE RIGHT LET'S HAVE A
STATE WHAT BILL SCHEDULE. NOW
THEY'RE AGAINST THIS TOMORROW
IF WE DID SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WE AGAINST THAT IT'S JUST THE
NATURE OF THINGS THAT YOU
CANNOT FUNDED BY IT BUT IT'S
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO GET THEIR
SUPPORT BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY. PUT THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE
HAVE BETTER WAYS TO TREAT ARE.
THE CAR COMMUNITIES AND ACHIEVE
PUBLIC SAFETY WITH THAT. AS
RIVAL. THANK YOU SO HERTZBERG.
HAVE A MOTION TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PER. CONSULTANT
CALL ROLL ON S. B. TWO C. TWO.
SB TWO SICK TO HER. D. PASTOR.
BROWN ON REDFORD I'D- NO.
TROUBLE NOTE. SKINNER SKINNER I.
WELL THE ROLE OPEN. WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
THROUGH ON IT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO YOU ARE FOUGHT
THERE WE HAVE- SENATOR. MELINDA
WITH US B. FOR CENTER WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED YOU MAY BE YOUR-
PRESENTATION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I DO WANT TO ASK I
HAVE TO WITNESSES HERE IN
PERSON TODAY TO TESTIFY WHERE
WOULD YOU LIKE THEM. YOU JUST
WANT TO BEHIND OKAY ALL RIGHTS
ALL CALL THEM UP. WHEN THEY'RE
READY R. EIGHT- I AM HERE TO.
S. B. THREE FIFTY ALEXANDER IS
LAW WHICH AIMS TO REDUCE
FENTANYL DEATHS SENATORS YOU
SHOULD HAVE ALL RECEIVED. THIS
BOOK. IN YOUR OFFICE IT WAS
DELIVERED EVERYONE'S OFFICE AND
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A
LOOK THROUGH THIS BOOK AND READ
ABOUT OF THE VICTIMS OF FATAL
POISONING IN HERE THAT CHOSE TO
SHARE THEM WITH US THIS STARK
HERE. THESE ARE THE LETTERS
THAT I RECEIVED FROM PARENTS
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WHO HAD
CHILDREN WHO DIED FROM FENTANYL
POISONING THESE ARE JUST
RECEIVED IN A FEW DAYS. THIS
DOESN'T EVEN ACCOUNT FOR ALL
THE DEATHS THAT HAVE. BEEN
CAUSED BY THIS DRUG. ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FENNO DEATHS ROSE
IN CALIFORNIA BY MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED PERCENT. BETWEEN THE
YEARS TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN. ZACH DDA WAS A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA STUDENT HE WAS A
TRACK STAR A STRAIGHT A STUDENT
A SELF TAUGHT MUSICIAN AND HAD
A GOAL OF ONE DAY GOING TO
STANFORD. AFTER WATCHING A
MOVIE WITH HIS FAMILY HE WENT
TO BED AFTER TELLING HIS FATHER
I HAD A GOOD TIME LOVE YOU DAD
GOOD NIGHT. THE NEXT DAY WHEN
ZACH DIDN'T ANSWER KNOCKED ON
HIS DOOR HIS DAD ENTERED HIS
ROOM. AND FOUND THE SON HE
LOVED SO MUCH SLUMPED OVER THE
COMPUTER GEEK KEYBOARD AT HIS
DESK UNRESPONSIVE. EXACTLY BY
WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS A
PRESCRIPTION PAIN PILL FROM
SOMEONE HE MET ON SNAPCHAT. IT
TURNED OUT TO BE FENNEL AND IT
WAS A LETHAL DOSE AND NOW
ZACH'S PARENTS LIKE SO MANY
OTHER WILL NEVER GET TO TELL
THEIR CHILD THEY LOVE THEM
AGAIN. ONE FINAL FIRST CAME
INTO THE UNITED STATES IT WAS
USED BY HARD CORE ST YEARS
YEARS USERS ADDICTED TO HEROIN.
NOW THE CARTELS ARE TRYING TO
DRY IN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS
HIGH SCHOOL KIDSCOLLEGE
STUDENTS. ADULTS WHO'VE NEVER
USED DRUGS OR DON'T HAVE AN
ADDICTION PROBLEM. THE
SYNTHETIC BUT NO WAS SOLD
ILLEGALLY AS A POWDER IT'S
DROPPED ON THE BLOTTER PAPER TO
PUT AN EYE DROPPERS AND NASAL
SPRAYS ARE MADE INTO PELLETS
THAT LOOK LIKE OTHER
PRESCRIPTIONS LIKE PERCOCET
XANAX- ADDERALL. FENTANYL IS
FIFTY TIMES STRONGER THAN
HEROIN IT'S SO POTENT THAT THE-
THAT AN AMOUNT THE SIZE OF
THREE GRAINS OF SUGAR IS LEGAL.
THE SUGAR PACKET THAT YOU'LL
FIND IN ANY DINER ANY COPY
STORE. HAPPEN THE SUGAR PACKET
IS A LETHAL DOSE OF HEROIN HALF
OF THE SUGAR PACKET. YOU TAKE
OUT ABOUT THREE GRAINS OF THE
SUGAR AND THAT'S A LETHAL DOSE
OF FENTANYL. THE REASON FENNEL
IS BECOMING SO POPULAR RETURN
WITH DRUG TRAFFICKERS IS IT
TAKES SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT TO
THAT OF HEROIN AND A LITTLE
FENNEL GOES A LONG WAY AND
MAKES A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY. THE
PROBLEM IS ALSO THAT IT'S SO
POTENT THAT JUST A SLIP OF A
HAND WHEN YOU'RE MIXING IT OR
RESIDUAL DUST OF FENTANYL IN A
BLENDER THAT YOU'RE USING TO
MIX THIS UP. RESULT IN A BATCH
THAT CAN KILL MULTIPLE USERS
INSTANTLY. THERE'S AN EMERGENCY
ROOM PHYSICIAN AND-
PSYCHIATRIST AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF MICHIGAN. HE SAID THAT HE
HAS DOCUMENTED CASES WHERE THEY
HAVE HAD TO GIVE A DOSE OF NOR
CAN WHICH IS A DRUG USED TO
REVERSE SOMEONE WHO'S
OVERDOSED. OR DAVE DAVE HAD TO
GIVE SOMEONE NOR CAN EIGHT
TIMES. TO REDUCE THE EFFECTS
EIGHT TIMES. FIRST RESPONDERS
ARE NOT EQUIPPED TYPICALLY BUT
THAT MANY DOSES OF NOR CAN. IT
IS NOT JUST HARDCORE DRUG USERS
DYING FROM FENTANYL IT IS MOM'S
IT IS COACHES IT IS LAWYERS
PIZZA DELIVERY GUYS. SOLAR
PANEL DELIVERS YOU NAME IT.
IT'S AFFECTING EVERYONE. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN PRINCE.
MUSICAL GENIUS IN THE INDUSTRY
HE DIED FROM TAKING COUNTERFEIT
BIKE IT IN THAT HAD FINALISED.
AND THE RATE OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN DEATHS FROM FENTANYL
IS GROWING THE FASTEST BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE AMERICA
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN DEATH RATE
INCREASED ONE HUNDRED AND 40%
EACH YEAR. FAKE FAT NO PILLS
CAN BE EASILY PURCHASED BY KIDS
ONLINE USING SNAPCHAT OR SOME
OTHER APP AND IT'S DELIVERED
RIGHT TO THEIR HOME YOU WOULD
NEVER EVEN KNOW IT. ACCORDING
TO AN NBC NEWS REPORT IN
JANUARY FEDERAL AUTHORITIES IN
SACRAMENTO ISSUED A MULTI COUNT
INDICTMENT ACCUSING TEN PEOPLE
FROM CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA OF
TRAFFICKING IN FENTANYL LACED
OXY CODE ON PILLS. PROSECUTORS
SAID WIRETAPS SHOWED THAT THE
DEFENDANTS WERE AWARE. THAT
MULTIPLE DEATHS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA HAD BEEN LINKED
TO THOSE PILLS AND THEY KEPT ON
SELLING THEM. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS
ALEXANDER CAP ALITO. DIED AFTER
TAKING A PILL THAT HAD FIVE
TIMES THE FATAL AMOUNT OF
ILLICIT FENTANYL. A FACT SHE
HAD NO IDEA OF WHEN SHE
PURCHASED THAT PILL SHE THOUGHT
SHE WAS TAKING THE PAIN
RELIEVER OXY CODE OWN. I HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH HER FAMILY
AND OTHERS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS TO CRAFT A
THOUGHTFUL PROPOSAL. SB THREE
FIFTY IS BASED OFF OF AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY THREE WHICH WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
WHICH REQUIRES THE COURT TO
ADVISE AN INDIVIDUAL CONVICTED
OF IT DO YOU AYE THE DRINKING
AND DRIVING COULD RESULT IN THE
DEATH OF ANOTHER PERSON AND IF
THEY CONTINUE THIS BEHAVIOR IN
KILL SOMEONE WHILE DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE. OF ALCOHOL
THEY COULD BE CHARGED WITH
MURDER THEY COULD BE CHARGED
WITH MURDER. NOT NECESSARILY
BUT THEY COULD BE. SB THREE
FIFTY WOULD REQUIRE THE SAME
ADVISEMENT BE READ TO AN
INDIVIDUAL CONVICTED OF
MANUFACTURING AND DISTRIBUTING
FENTANYL. THIS BILL WILL HELP
PROVIDE THE KEY ELEMENT OF
IMPLIED MALICE FOR A PROSECUTOR.
TODAY MARKS FIFTEEN DAYS TO THE
DAY THAT ALEXANDER CAP LATER
DIED FROM FENTANYL. FIFTEEN
MONTHS SORRY TODAY ALSO MARKS
SIX MONTHS TO THE DAY THAT ALEX
NIBBLED DIED FROM FENTANYL. I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU NOW FOR
YOUR FULL ATTENTION SENATORS AS
YOU LIVING CARE LISTEN
CAREFULLY TO THE TESTIMONY OF
MY TWO WITNESSES MATT COMPLETO
ALEXANDER'S DAD IN AMY NEVIL
ALEX'S MOM BOTH OF WHOM LOST
THEIR CHILDREN TO FEND OFF.
MATT WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
EACH WITNESS TWO MINUTE TO
THEIR TESTIMONY TWO MINUTES
APIECE THANK YOU. IT'S UP TO
YOU WHICH ONE GOES FIRST MAN.
IN SEPTEMBER TWO AND A HALF.
TWO FIVE. YOU KEEP YOUR THERE'S
ALSO. WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO
KEEP YOUR MASK ON PLEASE LOGIN.
SORRY MY GLASSES GET UP WHEN HE
I DID MY BEST. MY NAY IS MATT
LEADER. I'M STAY HERE BEFORE
YOU DID. IS THE FATHER OF ALEX.
WHO IS KILLED ON DECEMBER TWO
THIRD TWO NINETEEN BUDGET
COUNTERFEIT PILL WHICH CAN ALL
THE OF FAT. NOTHING WE DO HERE
TODAY WILL BRING BACK MY
DAUGHTER FOR THOSE WE HAVE
ALREADY LOST. I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE THOUSANDS WILL BE
DECEPTIVELY AND FATALLY
POISONED IN THE FUTURE IF WE
DON'T TAKE DECISIVE ACTION NOW.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN DRAFTED WITH
ONE GOAL TO SAVE LIVES. THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT PUNITIVE.
IT'S PREVENTATIVE. MODELED
AFTER THE SUCCESSFUL WATSON
WROTE SB THREE FIFTY PROVIDES
DRUG DEALERS WITH A FAIR
WARNING. IT INFORMS THEM THAT
THE DRUGS THEY ARE SELLING
COULD RESULT IN SOMEONE'S DEATH.
WITH FENTANYL BEING SOLD UNDER
FALSE PRETENSES TO UNWITTING
CONSUMERS SB THREE FIFTY IS AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE TO A
DEADLY THREAT. BEFORE AFFECTED
ALL EMERGED ON THE DRUG SCENE
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN DRUG DEALERS
HAD SOME BASIS FOR CLAIMING
THAT THEY WERE NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR DEATHS THAT RESULTED FROM
SELLING AND LET'S IT DRUGS.
HOWEVER THIS IS CHANGED TODAY
PEOPLE ARE BEING DECEIVED
PARTICULARLY WHEN CONSUMING
COUNTERFEIT PILLS PRESSED TO
MIMIC LEGITIMATE
PHARMACEUTICALS INSTEAD THEY
CONTAIN NOTHING BUT A NEUTRAL
BASE AND FENTANYL. FIFTY SPENT
ACT IS BEING DONE SOLELY FOR
FINANCIAL GAIN WITH RECKLESS
DISREGARD FOR HUMAN LIFE.
ELICIT THAT AND ALL THOSE DONE
WHAT NO OTHER BLACK MARKET HAS
EVER DONE. IT KILLS WITH A SINK
USE. IT IS KILLING THE
COUNSELOR USER THE FIRST TIME
DRUG USER AND THOSE SELF
MEDICATING. THIS GROUP OF NON
ADDICTS IS NOW THE FASTEST
GROWING AND LEAST RECOGNIZE
DEMOGRAPHIC FOR DRUG RELATED
DEATHS IN THE U. S. ADDICTS ARE
NOT IMMUNE FROM FAT AND ALL
EITHER MANY ARE BEING ROBBED OF
THEIR CHANCE TO RECOVER. IN
THIS NEW ERA OF ILLICIT FAT AND
ALL WE MUST BE CAPABLE OF
IMPOSING SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
FOR THOSE WHO CONTINUE TO SELL
DEADLY DRUGS EVEN AFTER THEY
KNOW THE DANGERS. ALEXANDER'S
LAW IS A WARNING THAT THE
DEALER CHOSE TO IGNORE IT AND
PROSECUTORS WILL HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO IMPOSE A STIFFER
PENALTY. AS A BORDER STATE
CALIFORNIA IS A HUB FOR ILLICIT
FENTANYL DISTRIBUTION ACROSS
THIS NATION WE ARE OBLIGATED TO
TAKE ACTION. I ASK THAT YOU
PASS THIS BILL ON TO THE FULL
SENATE FOR DEBATE. OUR CHILDREN
ARE DYING FAMILIES ARE
SUFFERING. AND WE NEED YOUR
HELP NOW MORE THAN EVER. WE
CANNOT BRING ALEX OR THE
THOUSANDS WE HAVE ALREADY LOST
BACK BUT HER LAW WILL SAVE
OTHERS. AS OUR LEADERS YOUR
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL TODAY WILL
DEMONSTRATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
PROTECT THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA FROM THIS RAPIDLY
GROWING DANGER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. MY NEXT
WITNESSES AMY NOVEL. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. MY NAME I AMY NOVEL
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. AND THIS IS
MY FOURTEEN YEAR OLD SON
ALEXANDER. ALEXANDER DIED NINE
MONTHS AGO TODAY AND JUNE
TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY.
AFTER TAKING A SINGLE PILL THAT
HE BELIEVED WAS AN OXY CODE OWN.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A
COUNTERFEIT TELL ME DEFENSE
NOW. I FOUND ALEX A DEAD ON THE
FLOOR OF HIS BEDROOM. THIS IS
HOW MOST OF OUR KIDS ARE DYING
IN THE NIGHT ALONE IN THEIR
BEDROOMS. ALEX THAT IS PULLED
FROM A DEALER HE CONNECTED WITH
ON SOCIAL MEDIA WE KNOW WHO THE
DEALER IS THIS DEALER IS STILL
SELLING HIS DRUGS ONLINE. AT
LEAST TWO OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
DIED FROM THE STEELERS
COUNTERFEIT PILLS. ONE BEFORE
ALEX AND ONE AFTER. THE YOUNG
MAN THAT DIED BEFORE ALEX DIED
IN FRONT OF THE DEALER IN THE
DEALER'S APARTMENT. ALEX WAS
DUPED BY THIS DRUG DEALER AND
THIS IS HAPPENING EVERY DAY.
ALEX BELIEVE HE WAS BUYING
OXYCODONE THAT'S WHAT HE
INTENDED TO TAKE AND HE WOULD
BE ALIVE TODAY EXCEPT FOR THE
FACT THAT THE DEALER SOLD HIM
DENTAL UNDER FALSE PRETENSES.
THIS IS DEALER NO HIS TOES ARE
DEADLY FAKES. IF NOT SB THREE
FIFTY WILL MAKE SURE HE IS
INFORMED JUST HOW DANGEROUS HIS
ACTIONS CAN BE. IF HE DOES NOTE
THAT IT'S MALICE IS NOT JUST A
SMALL TIME STREET DEALER HE'S
COMMITTING FRAUD AND MURDER.
ALEXANDER'S LAW. GIVES A LOT
OUT AUGUST FOR THE TOOLS TO
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE. SINCE AN OLD.
AND IT'S IMPACT IS FELT IN
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE FROM
THE FIRST TIME USER TO THOSE
SUFFERING WITH LONG TERM
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PEOPLE
ARE BEING POISONED BY THIS
DEADLY CHEMICAL. FENTANYL DOES
NOT DISCRIMINATE. IT'S KILLING
EVERY RACE EVERY GENDER RICH OR
POOR AND IT'S KILLING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AT DISPROPORTIONATE
RATES. NO ONE DESERVES TO DIE
THIS WAY. YOU MIGHT BE ASKING
YOURSELF SO WHERE'S THIS DRUG
DEALER NOW. IT SHOULD COME AS
NO SURPRISE YOU THAT HE IS FREE
LIVING HIS LIFE CONTINUING TO
SELL DRUGS TO UNSUSPECTING KIDS
AND ADULTS. WELL MY CHILD IS IN
THE CURRENT. HOW DOES IT IS
BETTER. THE GAME IS CHANGED AND
WE NEED NUMERO. SB THREE FIFTH
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT. WHAT IN
FACT MY ALEX. BUT IT WILL
SURELY SAY OTHERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I AM NOW GOING TO
ASKS ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE FIFTY HERE AND ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE IF SO WE WOULD
URGE YOU TO STATE YOUR NAME-
AND YOUR POSITION. IN THIS ROOM
BRITISH JUST AGAIN JUST COME TO
THE MICROPHONE. AND STATE ONLY
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION
WE'VE ALREADY HAD PRIMARY
TESTIMONY ON THE ON THE MOTION.
SEVEN ON. MY NAME'S LORD DEAR
THIS IS MY SON'S ACREE DID HERE
AND ON HIS HE WAS KILLED THREE
MONTHS AGO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
CONNECT WITH US. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS CAMMY BELL C. THIS
IS MY SON EMAIL LEOS STEVEN
JOFFE. HE DIED ON MARCH NINTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY BUT NINETEEN
YEARS OLD. AND I GREATLY
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY AND I
ASK THAT YOU DO THE SAME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS TIME REPORT THAT I
AM HERE REPRESENTING MY DEAD
SON DANIEL JOSEPH PORT THE
JOHNSON WHO DIED ON APRIL THE
SIX TWENTY TWENTY DUE TO
FENTANYL POISONING HE WAS ONLY
SIXTEEN AND A HALF YEARS OLD
AND IS NOW GONE. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY THANK
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. HELLO
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ED TURNED
IN A LOST MY TWENTY TWO YEAR
OLD SON TO A COUNTERFEIT
PERCOCET PILL IN MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE FIFTY WHICH WERE RE
BOOKED REDUCE BOTH DRUG DEATHS
AND DRUG RELATED
INCARCERATIONS. BY PROVIDING A
WARNING TO FIRST TIME CONVICTED
OFFENDERS. ARE STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU FOR
THIS. HI MY NAME'S KRISTEN
CABALLERO AND THIS IS MY
DAUGHTER ALEXANDER CAPITA. AND
YOU KNOW SHE HAD SUFFERED
INSOMNIA HOME FROM COLLEGE JUST
WANTED TO TAKE HALF A PILL SHE
GOT OFF SNAPCHAT SO SHE CAN
SLEEP AND I FOUND HER DEAD IN
THE- IN HER BEDROOM IN THE
MORNING. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THREE FIFTY PLEASE WE CAN'T
KEEP HAVING THESE CHILDREN DIE
LIKE THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS MY NAME IS STEVE OLSON.
I'M RETIRED POLICE OFFICER FOR
THE CITY OF SAMPOERNA DINO ON
JANUARY TWENTY SECOND OF TWENTY
TWENTY MY WIFE FOUND MY
DAUGHTER. HER BOYFRIEND DEAD IN
THEIR APARTMENT IN THE CITY OF
REDLANDS. THERE WERE TWO OF
FOUR VICTIMS THAT WERE KILLED
THAT DAY BY PRINT NOT
POISONING. WE'VE CAREFULLY
CONSTRUCTED THIS BILL WITH THE
SUGGESTION THAT A WARNING WILL
BE EFFECTIVE IN TRYING TO CURB
THE SCOURGE OF THIS POISON.
BEING SPREAD THROUGHOUT OUR
SOCIETY I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT IN
HONOR OF OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE AND FORTY. TWO
OH THREE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE FIFTY.
INA NOW WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AGAIN WE
WILL STAGE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. PLEASE THE MARQUEZ
AND THIS IS MY SAN FERNANDO
SANCHEZ WHO'S PASSED AWAY ON
MARCH TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWENTY
pSUPPORT. SB THREE FIFTY IT WAS
MY ONLY CHILD THANK YOU THANK
YOU THERE TO WITNESS. I AM SURE
THE ANTENNAS. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY DAUGHTER ATHENA IS
A PITA THAT DIED NOVEMBER
SEVENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY WHICH
WAS ONE OF THE SIX DEATHS. IN
THE SAME WEEK PER AND HER GROUP
OF VALUE SHARES DUE TO
FACTIONAL. I SUPPORT STRONGLY
SB THREE FIFTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS. FIRST I WANT TO I
WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO SPEAK TO
YOU. THIS IS MY BELOVED SON
CHRISTIAN JACK TAYLOR HE WAS
ONLY TWENTY ONE WHEN HE PASSED
ON JULY NINETEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY FROM SENTINEL POISONING.
IT'S TOXICOLOGY CAME BACK HERE
FENTON ALL CRUSHED WITH TYLENOL.
IT WAS THE- HELLO THAT WAS SOLD
TO HIM AS PERCOCET. BUT IT HAD
THE FIVE TIMES LEGAL DOES.
ATTENTION ALL. AND AUGER THAN
FIFTY TIMES STRONGER THAN
HEROIN. MY SON SUFFERED FROM
ANXIETY. HE WHAT TO THE DOCTORS
OVER A DOZEN DOZEN TIMES IN THE
HOSPITALS ARE TRYING TO GET
HELP FOR HIS ANXIETY BUT ARE
THEY WANT TO PRESCRIBE HIM
ANYTHING. HE CRIED OUT OF THE
PRESENCE BUT HE WASN'T HE
WASN'T DEPRESSED HE WAS
SUFFERING FROM ANXIETY AND SO
HE TURNED TO DRUG DEALERS AT
HIS SCHOOL CAMPUS HE WAS A
SENIOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARIZONA. AND HE WAS GOING INTO
HIS SENIOR YEAR TO GRADUATE.
THIS SPRING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESTORE LIFE AHEAD OF THEM.
THANK YOU I'M. WE NEED TO MOVE
FARTHER THAN YOU IMAGINE WE
NEED TO MOVE TO- I DON'T WANNA
BE INSENSITIVE BUT WE NEED TO
MOVE TO OUR NEXT WITNESS WE
JUST NEED YOUR POSITION I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. A WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAURA. AND
THIS IS MY SIXTEEN YEAR OLD SON
JOSEPH. DOES IT WAS POISONED
WITH FENTANYL FENTANYL NOVEMBER
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY. FOUR
MONTHS FOUR MONTHS AGO IT WAS
MY CHILD. TOMORROW IT CAN BE
YOUR CHILD YOUR GRANDCHILD OR
ONE OF YOUR LOVED ONES. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
FIFTY. AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING JOS. IZZY AND PAUL
THEIR MOMS COULDN'T BE HERE BUT
I'M HERE FOR THEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY NAME
IS MERRY TURNING ON AND-
CHARLIE TURNAROUNDS MONTHS
CHARLIE DIED ON MAY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY. HE TOOK WHAT HE
THOUGHT WAS A PERCOCET FIRST
BAD BACK. BUT IT TURNED OUT TO
BE A COUNTERFEITING POISONOUS
PILL. THAT WAS MADE OF FENTANYL
FENTANYL WE CALL FEDERAL.
PLEASE VOTE FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. SOME OTHER
CHILDREN DON'T HAVE TO DIE. I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THIS. HI MY NAME IS LISA
WYCHERLEY. AND I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT MY DAUGHTER LACEY
WYCHERLEY. THAT WILL FOREVER BE
TWENTY BECAUSE SHE WAS POISONED
BY FENTANYL I GUESS. TWENTY
FIFTY THOUSAND NINETEEN. SHE
DID NOT WANT TO DIE. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY. THANK
YOU FOR THIS. I'M SENATORS I'M
JIM SHOALS HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
SON NECK. NICK WAS POINTS
POISONED ONE HALF. TABLET OF
THE BILL CAN CONTAINING FAT
MALL IN JUNE LAST YEAR. IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN TWENTY SIX.
TODAY THAT'S SENATOR MELENDEZ
STATED THAT THIS PROBLEM IS
GROWING EXPONENTIALLY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU USE
YOUR POWER TODAY TO GET SB
THREE FIFTY OUT OF COMMITTEE
WITH AN AYE VOTE YOU WILL
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY SAVE
LIVES THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
ADDRESS. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT OF. A SPEED.
THREE FIFTY. SEE NO ONE COMING
FORWARD MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES CAN YOU AYE
LET US KNOW HOW MANY CALLS WE
HAVE IN QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIFTY AND WILL BEGIN WITH
TESTIMONY. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE- SEVEN EIGHT. PHONE LINES
INTO TO SPEAK THE BILL- AND
PARDON ME I STAND CORRECTED
MISTER CHAIR OF THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS ATTEMPTING TO
QUEUE UP TO SPEED IS OF GROWING
QUICKLY WE ARE NOW AT. TWENTY
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY NINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARMY JUST A
MOMENT PLACE. ONE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY NINE IF YOU CAN HEAR ME
PLEASE BE. JUST A MOMENT. RT
MISTER CHAIR. WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO LINE. ONE EIGHTY ONE. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. HI THIS IS
SHANNON KNOX I'M WITH COMMUNITY
HEALTH PROJECT LOS ANGELES- AND
WE WANT TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
IT ADDRESSES THE SITUATION AT
HAND. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE ONLY AT THIS TIME- TAKING-
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GOING TO
GO TO ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. PARDON
ME JUST A MOMENT. LET ME GO TO
LINE. NINETEEN CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. I YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE
TAKING IN CORPORATE I'M IN NOW.
SEVENTEEN HELLO SENATORS CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. YES MY NAME'S
TIMOTHY MARTIN AND- I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ALEXANDER NEVIL HE'S
MY- HAVE YOU AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIFTY
BUT THOUGH IT'S A WARNING TO
ANYBODY WHO SELLS ILLEGAL OR
LEGAL DRUGS LACED WITH THAT NOW
I THOUGHT ESTABLISHES YOU KNOW
THAT THE HUMAN LIFE HAS VALUE
AND WE SHOULD AT LEAST AT THE
VERY LEAST GIVE THEM A WARNING
THAT MAYBE IN THE FUTURE WHEN
THEY KILL SOMEBODY. THERE COULD
BE CONSEQUENCES. I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND TIME THANK YOU.
BLIND A. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. HI MY NAME IS KAREEM
MATTERS AND I'M CALLING FROM
ELDORADO HILLS I AM A CONCERNED
PARENT AND A FRIEND OF LOWER
GEAR ANOTHER AFFECTED YEAR- AS
IT STANDS RIGHT NOW IN THIS
MOMENT DRUG CARTEL LIKE THIS IN
THE LOWER CARTEL HAVE THE UPPER
HAND. AND THE WAY FOR SPENT NON
POISONINGS IN THE NORTHWESTERN
DIRECTLY LINKED TO THIS TO THEM
YOU KNOW I THINK BECAUSE OF THE
DDA BECOMING A NATIONAL AND
GLOBAL PROBLEM SENATORS YOU
HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL TO MEET
THE WAY MOST EFFECTIVELY BY
PASSING THIS BILL. DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR SAMMONS YOUR BILL TO
OUR CALLERS PLEASE- AT THIS
TIME WE NEED TO HAVE JUST YOUR
NAME YOUR AGENCYAND WHETHER OR
NOT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE
BILL AT THIS TIME. WE'RE TAKING
IN SUPPORT PLEASE. LINE TWELVE.
OUR ME JUST A MOMENT. I'M GONNA
GO TO LINE AT. ONE SIXTEEN. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME
IS TERRA FRANKLIN- TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF MY SON AND BEST
FRIEND ISRAEL IS THE RYLAN
FRANKEL WITH. HE DIED MARCH
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY
DAYS BEFORE HIS NINETEENTH
BIRTHDAY AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I BAG
THAT YOU BE THE SAME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
YES. MY NAME IS BURKE CABALLERO
I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
LITTLE CATCHER ALEXANDRA
CAPITAL L. INSTEAD FROM
SENTINEL. I AM IN FULL OF THIS
BILL IN A BAG THAT YOU SUPPORT
IT TOO SO I UNDERSTAND DON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH. THE PAIN IN
MY HEART THAT WE HAVE THANK YOU.
LINE. EIGHTEEN HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. MY NAME IS TINA
PRUITT I'M CALLING ABOUT MY SON
LOGAN ALBERT HARRIS WHO JUST
TURNED TWENTY TWO- ON OCTOBER
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY. NOT
KILL KILLED MY SON. AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE AND I YOU TO ACT
NOW. I THANK YOU TO DO
SOMETHING TO PUT THE PUBLIC.
AND TO SAVE OTHER LIVES. FIND.
ONE THIRTY FIVE. I'M SURE
MEMBERS LOOKING A BRANDED UP ON
BEHALF OF THE L. A. COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SUPPORT.
LINE. ONE OH ONE. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER BRYAN I'M HERE TODAY
FOR MY SON LANDON JACK BREDELL
WAS POISONED WITH FEDERAL ON
FEBRUARY TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND I PRAY THAT YOU WILL.
THANK YOU. FIND. ONE TWENTY
ONE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MY NAME IS KENNY ROGERS AND.
NINE ONE TWENTY ONE WE'RE SORRY
YOUR LINE CUT OUT. I'M GONNA GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO. HELLO
ARE YOU ARE YOU KNOW THERE ARE.
I WANTED TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT- MY SON DIED IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN I WANTED TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT ACCORDING
TO THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH. 47% OF ALL TWELFTH
GRADERS IN THIS YEAR. TRIED
SOME FORM OF ILLICIT DRUGS NOW
THAT CATEGORY DOES NOT INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE MARIJUANA. SO WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS- A
ROULETTE GAME WHERE ONE OUT OF
EVERY TWO KIDS IS GOING TO BE
EXPOSED TO THAT TYPE OF DANGER.
AND THEN THE CALLER WILL. WE'VE
HAD- TO LEAD WITNESSES- SPEAK
AND I APOLOGIZE BUT AT THIS
TIME DUE TO THE RESTRICTIONS
UNDER COVER NINETEEN WE ARE
ONLY LIMITED AT THIS TIME. WITH
SPEAKERS IN- IN SUPPORT AND WE
JUST NEED TO AT THIS TIME TO
STATE YOUR NAME THE AGENCY THAT
YOU'RE PRESENTING AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I APOLOGIZE. FIND ONE
EIGHTY TWO. PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT I APOLOGIZE JUST MOMENTS.
I'M GOING TO GO TO LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. BOB THIS IS JOHN LOCAL
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE COALITION OF
PUBLIC OFFICE. REPORTS SERVICE.
INCORPORATE BY LET ALL OF THE
ELOQUENCE. BEFORE US THIS IS A
GOOD SENSE BILL. A MAN SENATOR
MELINDA WE'RE COMING FOR WITH
THIS THE STRONG STRONGLY. BY.
SIXTEEN YES THIS IS KRISTIN
PARDON BOMET DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
BUT ALSO TO OFFER ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THE COMMITTEE
NEEDS THANK YOU. BY. FORTY
NINE. BY FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE HAVE TO MOVE ON TO
LINE. SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. M. PARDON ME WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
LINE A ONE NINETY SIX POINT ONE
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU. THIS IS DEBBIE AND
KEVIN TURNAROUND IN THE COURT
OF OUR LETTING MATTHEW CHARLIE
DIED OF POISONING PLEASE
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY. THANK
YOU. WHY NO. ONE ZERO FOUR. ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR. WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN. HELLO HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES MA'AM ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN YEAH HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES I AM PLEASED
AHEAD THIS IS YOUR LEARN MUCH
MY NAME IS YOLANDA MACE AND-
UNFORTUNATELY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE ACCORDING TO
HELP SAVE LIVES MY- FIND. ONE
SIXTY FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
MERCEDES INDIA'S I'M A
GRANDPARENT OF CHRISTIAN JAMES
YOU KNOW HOW TIME PASSED AWAY
JANUARY SIXTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MY GRANDSON HAD
DIRECTION EITHER GRADUATED FROM
HIGH SCHOOL. THANK YOU JOHN AND-
PASSED AWAY AND FROM TAKING A
PILL DEFINABLE THE CORNER IT
WAS COMPLETELY 1100% SENTINEL
I'M TAKING YOU GUYS TO CLEAN
PLEASE. I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIFTY MY PAST THANK. LINE.
FIFTY THREE. WHY ONE FIFTY
THREE A ONE OPEN. YOU I. MY
NAME IS BEING HELD ALL GO. TO
MY NEXT. FOR THE PROGRAM BY
BANKS AND ALL. REPORTER TWENTY
FIRST BUT AND SHE SUPPORT. THE
GREAT THAT. NINE ONE SIXTEEN.
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO LINE
TWENTY TWO. HI MY NAME IS
RETREAD ARMED IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FIFTY MY NEPHEW
NOAH DIED OF SHRAPNEL LAST
APRIL ELEVENTH PLEASE PRACTICE
DISABLED. THANK YOU BYE EIGHTY
NINE. HI MY NAME IS CARLA MY
SON DANIEL ELISHA FIGUEROA DIED.
NUMBER SIXTEEN TWENTY TWENTY HE
WAS POISONED BY SPENDING ALL IN
THE FORM OF A PRESCRIPTION
PILL. I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THAT B. THREE FIFTY THREE
SUPPORTED AS WELL. THANK YOU.
WELL. HELLO MY NAME IS OLGA
MENDOZA I AM CALLING ON BEHALF
OF MY SON DANIEL YOUR FIGUEROA
WHO WAS TWENTY YEARS OLD DIED
OF SENTINEL WHAT YOU NEED I AM
IN SUPPORT FOR SB FIFTY I HOPE
YOU ARE ABLE ALIVE GOD BLESS
YOU. BLIND FIFTY NINE. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES. HI MY
NAME IS VIRGINIA COULD I'M WITH
PARENTS AGAIN DALLAS MARC. AND
ON BEHALF OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY WHICH WILL SAVE LIVES.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE ZERO FIVE
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS BARBARA BURRATA IN MY
NEPHEW HE DIED IN THANK YOU ALL
FOR A LIVING AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. HE THREE THIRTY. LINE
TWENTY SEVEN- MY NAME IS GUY
CAL POLY. AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF MY
SISTER ALEX THAT I LOG. MY.
SEVENTY FIVE. YES I'M
INTERESTED A BIAS ON MY MOTHER
ARNOLD W. OR IS V. THREE FIFTY
ONE YEARS AND THERE IS TO
SUPPORT US MAKE JUSTICE FOR MY
SON ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DRIVE ON
NOVEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
AND ALL DIALOGUE AND LYFT DO TO
A FRIEND COMING APPOINT THE
NAME. IT ONLY TAKES TWO GROUNDS
MILACRON FOR A PERSON TO BE
PLACED IN A STRUGGLE TO SUPPORT
AND. THREE THREE FIFTY THANK
YOU. BLIND EIGHT. MY NAME IS
MELISSA MARTIN MY NEPHEW
ALEXANDER NEPHEW WHO DIED AT
FOURTEEN UNDER TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY AND I SUPPORT SB
THREE FIFTY. LINE. NINETY FOUR.
MY NINETY FOUR YEAR ONE OPEN.
LET ME. START HI I AM A
INTERNET AND YOUR AND YEAH
RIGHT SON. ALEXANDER DOUBLE HE
WAS FOR YEAR OLD. PASSED AWAY
ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY AND I RECORDED THE BILL
ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO THE
EVIDENCE. AS FAR AS HOW THIS
HUGE- ARE DEALT WITH IN PLACES
LIKE PORTUGAL IN OREGON WHERE
THEY HAVE DECRIMINALIZED USE.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO LINE.
ONE NINETY THREE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. BRAINER AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE MY
COUSIN MICHAEL WHO PASSED AWAY
TWO YEARS AGO. BLIND ONE SIXTY
FIVE. YES HI MY NAME IS TONY
BERADA AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF MY NEPHEW MICHAEL- DEARLY
MISS YOU PLEASE PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. LINE ONE
NINETY NINE. GOOD MORNING
LIEUTENANT SURELY THE WILLIAMS
NUMBER EIGHTY NO SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ON BEHALF OF SHERIFF
MAKE MAN IN STRONG SUPPORT. BY
TWENTY SIX- HI- I'M CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES OKAY I MIGHT TO
MATTERS AND I'M IN FOR THE-
ADULT. NINE ONE NINETY FOUR.
THREE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES HI MY
NAME IS MEREDITH PASSION AND I
STRONGLY AND PASSIONATELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
EMILY OF THE LG AND THE LG
FAMILY. BY. TWO OH SEVEN. FIND
TO A SEVEN YEAR ONE IS OPEN.
YES HI MY NAME'S MEGAN YEAH I
LOST MY NEPHEW ARE THE VITALS
ON NOVEMBER FIRST TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN. BONTA NOW POINTING I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX. NINE
FIFTY ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
WAYNE CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
SON GAVIN GETTING RAIN DIED AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY FOUR WITH
WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS A HALF OF A
DAN ACTION AND AS IT TURNED OUT
IT WAS NOT WASTING I'M
INTRAPARTY. THREE FIFTY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. BLINDLY. TWO
HI MY NAME IS DOUGLAS WAYNE MY
SON GAVIN DIED ON JANUARY
SECOND OF THIS YEAR FROM
TRENTON ALL POISONING. WE
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY PLEASE
VOTE YES. NINE ONE FIFTY TWO.
HI MY NAME IS GABE JIMENEZ- I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY SON
JACOB GABRIEL JIMENEZ. WAS
POISONED BY FEDERAL ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY. I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE FIFTY AND- I URGENTLY ASK
YOU DO YOU ARE YOU THE SAME
VOTE YES THANK YOU. WHY. TWO
HUNDRED. THE MORNING UNTIL THE
SECOND I AM WITH ALEXANDER
LEVEL FOUNDATION I AM ALSO
CURRENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
EMPLOYEE OF OFFICER TWENTY ONE
YEARS I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE FIFTY THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS
ROGER COLLINS AND- I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MY STEP SON
SPENSER NEWSOME. DIED OF AN
OPIOID. BURKE TWENTY TWENTY
THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE FIFTY BANK COMMITTEE
MEMBERS REQUEST THAT YOU COULD
DO THE SAME. THE CHARGES LIKE
HOW BOB LINE NINETY FIVE. I DID.
MY NINETY FIVE YEAR LIARS OPEN
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES MY
NAME IS MARIA ORTEGA- WITH- A-
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN I
CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT MY SON
ADRIAN THE HIT. HE PASSED AWAY
FEBRUARY ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
I FOR THE MURDER OF MY INFANT
POISONING. ARE THE ONES TAKING
UP MARKET THAT FORTY INSOMNIA
BUT WHAT GIVEN A BREAK BUT
BUILT REAL. ME AND MY FAMILY.
AS THREE AND I YOUR PARDON AND
SUPPORT AND THREE FIFTY
ALEXANDER LAW. IT IS ONLY IN A-
JUST LIKE BUT DURING INVITE A
LOT I BEG TO PUT TO ARE YOU
BECAUSE LAW WELL NO SAVE MY SON
LIFE. BUT IT MADE YOUR. PLEASE
REPORT IT THANK YOU FOR. MY ONE
EIGHT EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN CORY A LITTLE BEHALF
THE STATE SHERIFFS IS IN
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU. WHY.
SEVENTY NINE. HELLO SEVENTY
NINE YEAR YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME'S. MY LITTLE BROTHER.
TWENTY TWENTY ONLY NINE YEARS
OLD. DO YOU KNOW BURKE THAT HE
WAS QUITE A BIT BY BUT NO I
DON'T WE I LAW ALWAYS COURSE.
WE. MY. SEVENTY SIX. HEAR ME.
HELLO YEAH HI MY IS NEEDED I'M
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF DURING.
I MAY BE POISONED BY PANEL. ON
LET TWENTY TWENTY ONE LIKE TO
SON COMMITTEE. MY DAUGHTER'S
BENCH PRESS. NO SHE LEAVE. ANY
NOW. SOMEONE I. COURT. B. BRING
BEADLOCK. NUMBER TWENTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SBIN ROCO
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU PLEASE
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY. YOUR
LINE. ONE OH FOUR. ONE ONE OF
FOR YOUR MIND IS OPEN. ONE OH
FOUR YES MA'AM I CAN HEAR OKAY
SORRY MY NAME IS JENNIFER
O'KEEFE AND I'M- SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF CENTER NEWSOME WHO
DIED OF BUT NOT PLACING ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. PLEASE PASS THIS BILL I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. THREE
FIFTY. FIND TO A LEVIN. HELLO
MY NAME. KERN I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN IN GLOUCESTER
COUNTY WHO CARED FOR CHILDREN
EXPOSED TO. MONTEL FRIEND. A
LOT OF ATTENTION BACK. IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY TWO TWO
WELCOME. THANKS SUPPORT SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY. YEAH TWO OR.
THREE HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEAH YES. MY NAME IS CLAUDIA
PATATAS IN BEHALF OF DANIEL
JOHNSON FORD FONG THE NINE. I
AM WITH THE S. B. FIFTY. NINE
EIGHTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS KIM
VANDER MEETING I SUPPORT SB
THREE FIFTY IN HONOR OF MY SON
RICHARD VANDER MEDIAN AND HIS
SIX WHEN THAT ALSO HAVE DIED
FROM FENTANYL POISONING IN AN
EIGHT MONTH. TIME FRAME IN
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA PLEASE
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY THANK
YOU. ONE ONE TWO SEVEN. HI MY
NAME IN A SECOND YEAH AND WE
LOST MY COUSIN ELIJAH- IN
SEPTEMBER AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY. NINE ONE OH SIX. HELLO
MY NAME IS JOHN ORTEGA
REPRESENTING MY COUSIN ADRIENNE
THAN IT IS WHO PASSED AWAY
FEBRUARY ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
WITH THE WORD MURDERED BY BUT
NOT BELIEVING I REGISTERED
NURSE THEY HAVE YOUR SUPPORT IN
THE BILL IN HONOR OF THOUSANDS
HAVE DIED WE NEED WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT TO SAVE LIVES I'M FOR
THE POOR. SB THREE FIFTY THANK
YOU. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. HI AND
DANIEL FLAWS B. AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CAPITOL
THEATER FAMILY LOST THEIR
DAUGHTER ALEXANDER TO AVOID
GOING INTO THE CONCERN FOR THE
FAN I HIGHLY SUPPORT SB THREE
FIFTY. WHY. NINETY TWO. YES
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS SUZANNE
I THINK GONE AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE MENTAL THAT
FAMILY- THE LAST YEAR AND
JANUARY LIKE YOU HAVE BIGGER A
LOT INCOMPATIBLE BIRD TWENTY
TWENTY- DUE TO THE HE WAS
POISONED BY SEN NOW I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTEEN I URGE
YOU TO DO THAT THING THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. WHY. ONE EIGHTY
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS LIZ MORELLO
I'M REPRESENTING FERNANDO
SANCHEZ A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
BOY WHO LOST HIS LIFEIN
GEORGIA CALIFORNIA ON MARCH
TWENTY SIX TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
FIFTY AND I ASK EACH OF YOU TO
DO THE SAME. TWO POINT. SIXTY
ONE. WHEN YOU'RE ONE OPEN HI MY
NAME IS JACK OF THE KEETA AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY ON BEHALF OF MY NOW MY
NEPHEW FERNANDO SANCHEZ WHO
PASSED AWAY. ONE YEAR AGO THIS
WRITING. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
SIXTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS FIRST
AT EIGHT AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF AT LEAST SOMEONE HAS
LOST HER ONLY SON MARCH TWENTY
SIX TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. AND I
FOR ASKING. NINE ONE TWENTY. MY
NAME. THE COUPLE SAM LAW THEIR
DAUGHTER ALEXANDER LITTLE I'M
IN. BY TO NINETEEN. ONE TWO
NINE NO ONE IS SO. WE'RE GOING
TO ON LINES. FOR FIVE. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY HI MY
NAME IS IN A NOVEL I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY BIG BROTHER
ALEXANDER NOVELS YOU NEED A
SINGLE TELL OF WHAT HE WAS
LOOKING I THINK HOLD ON AND IT
HAPPENS YOU'VE BEEN PLAYING.
I'M NOT SPENT PROBABLY KILLED
FOUR PEOPLE AND I. SUPPORT IT.
LIKE YOU SAID. ONE TWO SEVEN.
OKAY YES. IS CHRISTOPHER JOHN
DEERE AND I AM THE FATHER
ZACHARY JOHN DEERE I'M A
RETIRED MILITARY VETERAN. AND
I'M DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE. THAT
HAVING BEEN CLOSE IN WITH
SENTINEL AS STRONG STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY. ZACKS
YOU AND I. THE GRANT. PRESIDENT
THE COUNTRY THANK. BY. FIFTY
ONE. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. MANY
HARPER WHEN I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF MY BROTHER GAVIN
WAYNE WHO DIED ON JANUARY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY
THANK YOU. FIND. ONE THIRTY
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS RENEE
CHRISTIANSON I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF MY DEAR FRIENDS THAT
DID YOUR FAMILY I'M ALSO A MOM
OF TWO YOUNG PEOPLE AND HAD NO
IDEA THIS WAS AN ISSUE IT'S
SOMETHING WE ALL NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT INCLUDING THOSE SELLING
THE COUNTERFEIT PILLS. THE
COURT THREE FIFTY THANK YOU.
LINE. FORTY EIGHT. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES ZERO ONE BASKET
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY
BELOVED SON JAKE UP PASSED AWAY
NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY AFTER TAKING A FAKE
XANAX I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
THREE FIFTY. ONE TWENTY. MORE.
MY NAME ONE I. THE NEW LINE.
TWELVE HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MY ALL. AND I'M HERE ON
THE PHONE GAGGAN BATTLE WHO.
FOR ON OUR JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I AM THANK YOU ALL
WE SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY ONE.
PARDON ME WE'LL HAVE TO MOVE ON
THE LINE SEVENTY SIX. SEVENTY
SIX ARE YOU THERE. HELLO BASED
PLEASE RESPOND. HI MY NAME IS
ONE OF THEM CALLING TO SAY I
SUPPORT AS THE TICKET STATE.
THANK YOU. I'M GOING TO ONE TO
TWENTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS MY
NAME'S RICHARD BUT THE FACT MY
GRANDSON IS. UNDER NOBLE THEN I
THOUGHT I WOULD SUPPORT THIS
BILL- WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR
CHILDREN IN THIS IS A GOOD
START. THANK YOU. BY. TWO
THIRTY ONE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. ASSEMBLY HERE I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
BROTHERS ARE. STAY AWAY- I WILL
BE ABLE TO JOIN HIS WEDDING OR
IS GRADUATION BUT I DID MANAGE
YOU KNOW I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SIXTY. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT OTHER THAN A PARADE OF
GRIEVING FAMILIES CAN CONVINCE
YOU THAT YOU'RE STILL NOT SO
PLEASE HAVE AN OPEN MIND ON THE
LETTER SPOKE. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY. WELL YOU KNOW WHAT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I REALIZE
THAT IF NOT WE HAVE TO MOVE ON
THE LINE WITH. SEVENTY SIX.
YOUR FIND SEVENTY SIX ZERO ONE
OPEN YES HELLO. I AM CALLING ON
THE OF THE ALL ON THIS MIKE WHO
WAS ONLY YEARS OLD AND I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT BILL SB. TWO
FOR. BLACKLINE. SEVENTY HELLO
YEAH AND THAT'S WHAT I DID
ONLINE SEVENTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU GONNA MOVE THE LAW
SIX ONE. PARDON ME. AN ATTEMPT
LINE FORTY JUST A MOM. FIVE
TWENTY FIVE YEAR ONE OF SOME. I
I'M CALL IN THE POOR OF MY
LITTLE BROTHER. MY CAL NECKLACE
JURADO. HE DIED AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY THREE TODAY IS ACTUALLY
HIS TWENTY FOURTH BIRTHDAY SO I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THAT SB.
THREE FIFTEEN. THANK YOU ONE TO
THIRTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CALIFORNIA I'M A
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY AN HONOR OF HONOR BUT BY
ALSO LOOK FOR THEM BY SPENT ALL
THANK YOU. BLIND TO. TWO HELLO
MY NAME IS MARIANNE ROCHE- TOLD
THE COURT AT THE BELL FOR
ALEXANDER CATHOLIC OUT MY
DAUGHTER SISTER. THE YOU. BY.
TWO THIRTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
LUCY TO BELIEVE- I'M HERE
REPRESENTING MY SON HATING
CHRISTIAN TO POLITO WHO PASSED
AWAY FROM SIGNAL TOXICITY ON
MAY THIRTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY HE RECEIVED A PILL
THAT HE THOUGHT WAS A OXY FROM
A FRIEND TWO DAYS AFTER
GRADUATION I SUPPORT SB THREE
FIFTY. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THAT
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. MY WRITER WOULD YOU
CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE TIME
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB. THREE FIFTY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THIS IS A FINAL CALL
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO- CALL UPON YOU
BY YOUR MIND NUMBER. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE. PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT. WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE QUEUING UP TO SMALL IN
STATURE. TO GO TO LINE. PARDON
ME. TO GO TO LINE SEVENTY LINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
IT THANK. I AM IN SUPPORT THREE
BEEN DECREASED SENATORS AND ALL
IS THE CRISIS AND THAT'S
RUNNING RAMPANT I LOST MY GRANT
ALEXANDER DOUBLE IN JUNE THAT
THE BILL. FIND. TWO FORTY ONE.
ONE TWO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH ON BEHALF OF YOUR
FAMILY WE WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT
SB THIRTY FIFTEEN. AN HONORABLE
I'VE NOT THAT I. THANK LINE.
FIFTY SEVEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HI MY NAME IS LISA JIMENEZ
OKAY MY SON JACOB JIMENEZ- HE
DIED SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY HE WAS MURDERED BY
SENTINEL AND I HOPE YOU'LL DO
THE RIGHT MORAL SAYING AND VOTE
YES ON SB THREE FIFTY AND I
WILL. THANK YOU. ONE TO THIRTY
EIGHT. MANY OTHER PEOPLE MIGHT
BE ALEXANDER. SACRAMENTO ALL
THE- NOW EIGHT. WHAT S. B.
THREE FIFTY AND ABOUT WHAT. AND
AS A REMINDER TO BY ANY OF OUR-
CO HOSTS WHO ARE STILL ON THE
LINE PLEASE USE YOUR VIEW
BUTTON THAT TIME. WANT. TO
TWENTY EIGHT. HI HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES. MY NAME IS
VICTORIA ANTENNAS MY SISTER AS
SEEN AS A TEENAGER DIED
NOVEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
SHE WAS TWENTY YEARS OLD HER
LIFE WAS CUT SHORT I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY I PRAY
THAT YOU GUYS SEE THIS AS AN
ISSUE AND THAT YOU DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. THANK YOU. TWO
TWENTY. I COULD HEAR ME. YES
HELLO HI MY NAME IS LUKE
CROCHET. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF ALEXANDRIA CAPELO- I'M- THE
UNCLE OF HER DAUGHTER AND I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY. AND ENERGY TO SUPPORT IT
ALSO. ONE TO TWENTY SEVEN.
LARRY MARSH CALIFORNIA. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. HI MY NAME IS
CINDY SAUNTER. I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MY SON DYLAN ON BOTH
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD WHOSE
PLEASANT ATTENTIONAL AND HOW
WAY ON MAY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY- I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE THIRTY. THANK YOU. BY TWO
FIFTEEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE
OKAY AND I AM THE MOTHER OF
JESSICA AND MAY LOOM I FOUND
DEAD. ON THE MORNING OF
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY. I AM IN COMPLETE S.
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIFTY THANK
YOU. FIVE ZERO NINE. HELLO.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES OKAY.
YOU BET I'M BRINGING UP THE TO
GIVE MY FULL SUPPORT TO AS-
THREE FIFTY- MY SON ALEXANDER
HOUSE THE WAY IN JULY OF LAST
YEAR FROM BEING POISONED TO
DEATH BY SENTINEL TRINITY TO
VOTE THIS BILL IT'S PAST. LINE
SIXTY SIX. MY NAME THAT CAN
START CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY
MY NAME IS KEIKO I'M HERE FOR
MY BANG NECKLACE SO THE PASSED
AWAY JAN TWENTY SIX I AM ALSO
EMERGENCY ROOM NURSE THANK MAKE
UNIQUE TERMINATION OF DEATH
BECAUSE WITH OUR EMS PARTNERS.
THANK YOU KNOW QUAKING WAY TOO
MANY PLEASE. A STRONGLY SUPPORT
THEMSELVES. NINE TO TWELVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT BLACK I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF MY CLOSE
FRIENDS THAT DON'T CERVANTES
YOU PASSED AWAY ON MAY TWENTY
TWENTY MY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LISTEN TO US AND PLEASE PASS SB
THREE FIFTY IT WOULD MEAN THE
WORLD TO ALL OF US READING
FAMILIES. THANK YOU. PINE TO
SIXTEEN. MY NAME IS MONA
LEONARDI MY SON MICHAEL IN RT
WAS MURDERED FEBRUARY TWENTY
FOURTH OF TWENTY TWENTY AT THE
AGE OF TWENTY YEARS OLD WHILE
AWAY AT COLLEGE SAN DIEGO. BY A
DRUG DEALER WHO SOLD THEM THE
FAKE PERCOCET YEAH CAT BUT IT
WAS REALLY FAST AND ALL. I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY AND BECKY TO SUPPORT. BY.
TWO TWENTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MARIA DONA AND I'M
CALLING IN PART OF MY DEAR
FRIEND TINA BURKE BE LOCKED HER
SON HER SON WAS KILLED AND
POISONED BY SENTINEL IN JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY PLEASE WE HAVE TO
PROTECT OUR KIDS BOB THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MY SEVENTY SEVENTH.
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT ONE
SEVENTY SO. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
OF ONE STOP AND- SO. THE LION.
OKAY TO MOVE ON THE LINE. FORTY
NINE. THANK FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CANARY. YES.
MAKE THIS THIRTY TIMES MORE
RISKY. THESE DEALERS MY NAME IS
CHARLES BEFORE IT. FOUR TWENTY
SOMETHING DAUGHTERS WE DON'T
NEED A PERSONAL DOCUMENT FAMILY
FIFTY THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT.
B. THREE FIFTY. FIND. ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. WELL ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
HAVE TO MOVE ON TO ONE TO
THIRTY NINE POINT THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PARDON ME
THAT ONE IS NOT AVAILABLE.
GOING TO GO TO LINE TWO TWENTY
FIVE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
MY NAME IS THE THAT CRISTIAN
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAM AS A TEDA. AND I
SUPPORT. SB. THREE FIFTY. ONE
ONE EIGHTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS CAROL SCHWEIKERT. I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY ON BEHALF OF. ALL OF THE
VICTIMS AND THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE SUFFERING FROM THIS.
PUTTING MINE AND MY SON DO.
WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS A PERCOCET
WHILE HE'S RECOVERING FROM
SURGERY AND IT WAS ALL. I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THREE YOU'LL HAVE TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. ONE SIXTY
NINE. ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
THE LINE EIGHTY TWO. MY NAME IS
JOEL WAYNE. MY GRANDSON GAVIN
DIED EARLIER THIS YEAR AND THEN
ALL RIGHT THANK VENTURA COUNTY.
HE WAS A BEAUTIFUL CALIFORNIA
BOY. SB. THREE ONE TWO OH FOUR.
HI MY NAME IS HERE TO STAY HERE
I'M REPRESENTING MY SON JONES
SAWYER WHO. AT THE WAY. MARCH
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY
TOMORROW WILL BE A ONE YEAR. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY
I ENCOURAGE YOU WANT EVERYBODY
TO GET OUT AND GET THIS PAST.
THANK YOU. TWO FORTY TWO.
MISTER MEMBERS RANCHO MOTOR
RESEARCHERS POLITICIANS NUMBER
HOPEFUL WITH TH CALIFORNIA
COALITION SCHOOL SAFETY PLACE
L. A. EMPLOYEE. YES OFFICERS.
ANALYSTS SAY THE SCHOOL
RESEARCH DIVISION STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT THE THANK YOU.
BY. TWO THIRTY. HI MY IS LISA
HE DID BELIEVE DAHLE. I SUPPOSE
S. B. FIFTY. I AM FOR MY SON.
HE DIDN'T BELIEVE ALL BEACH
SEVEN WHO PASSED AWAY FROM NO
POINT. THANK YOU. TWO FORTY
NINE. HELLO JERRY BRADFORD BY
JUST AND CAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER KENNEDY I'M A FRIEND
OF THE DID CAMP AND JACK HERE
HE DIED THREE MONTHS CONTENT
NOT QUITE. I SUPPOSE SB THREE
AN I ASK YOU ABOUT. SENATORS TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. PLEASE BE
LEADERS ON THE SUPPORT ISSUE.
THANK YOU. BY TWO THE VERY.
TWENTY FIFTY THREE A ONE IS
OPEN. YES HELLO. YES YES MY
NAME IS MICHELLE AMPLE I'M FROM
HARRISBURG PENNSYLVANIA. MY SON
NOAH SPANGLER CAME RIVERSIDE.
YOU GO TO TEEN CHALLENGE HE WAS
BARE GRADUATED. OVER FOURTEEN
MONTHS LIVE BEER STOBER RIGHT
AT ONE AND DIED PLEASE. B.
THREE FIFTY MY SON AND MY
DAUGHTER HERE ALSO THEY ALSO
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL WAIT.
BLIND. TWO FIFTY FOUR. FOR ME
WAS NOT A BRIEF FACTORS THAT
LINE GOING TO GO TO LINE. TWO
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YEAH I
THANK YOU GUYS FOR YOUR TIME
I'M CALLING BECAUSE MY GOD SON
DANIEL ALLEGED FIGUEROA. THE
STAR ATHLETE HAD A PROMISING
FUTURE AND DIED IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FROM THAT
KNOCKDOWN MY NAME THROUGH
BECAUSE HARRIS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF. SB THREE FIFTY AND
I ASK THAT YOU GUYS JOIN US
THANK YOU. ONE TO SIXTY FOUR-
THIS IS A NEIGHBOR THERE IN I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT YOU KNOW THE
GREEN AND ONE FAMILY. AND- HOW
YOU GUYS AND BUILDING. SB.
THREE BLIND. SIXTY NINE. BY TWO
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YES. YES MY NAME IS
ROSE MARIE PINA ALL I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MY GRANDSON ISAIAH
THOMAS WHO PASSED AWAY JANUARY
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DUE TO
NO HE WAS NOT A USER TRIED IT
ONCE AND PASSED AWAY I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIFTY
ON THE BEHALF OF OUR BOUNTY
GONZALEZ PIGNON BOB I GOT THEM
I THANK YOU I HOPE THAT YOU DO.
THANK SHE. ONE TWO SEVENTY.
JUST A MOMENT. SEVENTY SIX. SIX
ONE UP AND. WHY TO SEVENTY
EIGHT. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. HI MY NAME IS ONE OF THE
BETTER AND THEN CLOSE THE BOOK.
BUT BASS THERE ARE OF MY BEST
FRIEND TO A AND I'M. BUT OF THE
GUIDE. I'M NOT. YEAH. SEVENTY
NINE SEVENTY SECURE ONES OPEN.
MY NAME. HI MY NAME IS MARLENE
VIA AND I LOST MY BROTHER HM
THAT HAS TO. ON FEBRUARY
ELEVENTH. TWENTY TWENTY. BUT.
YOU NEED TO. ALEXANDER LAW AND
THREE FIFTY IT'S ONLY INVITED
THREE JUST LIKE DRINKING AND
DRIVING BALK AT THANK YOU TO
PROTECT OUR YOUTH BECAUSE- LAW.
WILL NOT SAVE. BUT RATHER LIFE
BUT IT WAS YOUR- YEAH. ONE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
MARK WHAT I AM THE MOTHER OF
THE LATE SIGNATURE AGAIN AND
THE FOUNDER OF DRUG INDUCED
HOMICIDE FOUNDATION. I TOLD THE
COURT OF SB THREE FIFTY THANK
YOU SENATOR MELINDA. BLIND. TO
NINETY TWO. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES HI MY NAME IS VERONICA
I AM CALLING ON BEHALF. ABOUT
BEING OF THE PIZZA. AND I
PRESSED ON THE SUBJECT ARE YOU
CLEAN AT. YEAH THANK YOU RIGHT.
BY NINETY. BUT ALLEN I AM THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COALITION AND I
AM A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
FAIR- THANK YOU AB. HELLO HI
YES MY NAME IS MARISSA
CABALLERO I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF MY SON ISAAC AND DOLLARS THE
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD DUE TO FACTIONAL
POISONING I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
THREE FIFTY. BY. TWO NINETY
FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS RUBEN
RODRIGUEZ LOOKS. AND I LOST MY
NEPHEW BACK IN NOVEMBER FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY. DUE TO FENTANYL
POISONING. BERMAN SUPPORT OF
THREE FIFTY S. B. D. FIFTY.
COMPARE PLEASE BROWSE THIS BILL
SO YOU FOR CAN. FOR THE END OF
OUR COMMUNITY. BLIND. NINETY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS ADAM.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. MY
NAME IS ANNA ESTRADA I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF AYE
FINANCE THAT YEAH. AGREE WITH
BILL SB THREE THIRTEEN FOR WE
THE PEOPLE.
IN AURORA COLORADO
POSITION OF. AND SUPPORTIVE SO
LET'S MOVE TO OUR CALLERS AND
OPPOSITION- SB THREE FIFTY
MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP THOSE
DOLLARS MISTER CHAIR I
APOLOGIZE WE DO ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON WILL TAKE THAT ONE
ADDITIONAL IN THERE AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. WHY. TO NINETY THREE. BY
TWO NINETY THREE OF ONE IS OPEN.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONCLUDE
THAT MISTER CHAIR. ARE WE
MOVING NOW TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WILL MOVE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND ARE
THERE ANY ONE PRESIDENT AND
FORTY TWO OH THREE FOODS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIFTY.
C. NINE LET'S MOVE NOW THE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. HEAR ANYONE IN
THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND
OPPOSITION UP SB THREE FIFTY.
SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE NOW WILL MOVE. TO RE
REFER REMOVED TO OUR- PRIMARY
WHICH IS APOLOGIZE ARE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION TO- SB THREE FIFTY
WE HAVE LIEUTENANT DIçN
GOLDSTINE AND THEN WE HAVE
PLANNED BACK OF SO WE WILL
START WITH THE TENET GOLDSTINE
PLEASE IN OPPOSITION YEP TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU TO
DISTINGUISH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
MY BROTHER WHO DIED FROM AN
OPEN DAY. AND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
A NONPROFIT GROUP OF POLICE
JUDGES ANOTHER CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROFESSIONAL CONTROLLER SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU POLICY. I AM
HERE IN OPPOSITION SB AGE
FIFTY. THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT LONG PRISON SENTENCE HE
HAD BY STATE OPEN. BOTH WHY.
HIGHER LEVEL DRUG MANY AND
DEALER ARE VERY CONNECT TO OUR
TO BE. THE MANY MANY USERS
PURCHASE THE FRONT FAMILY. MANY
OF THE TRANSIT OCCUR NOT BE A
RECALLS A MA'AM. AND A VALUABLE
LOOKS AT THE USE THIS BUT
RATHER BE TWENTY BY AND- WHICH
USED FOR. THE HARSH PUNISHMENT.
BY THE WOULD FALL ON WHO ARE
SELLING ALL PART. DRUG PROBLEM.
READ MORE MONEY AT AN ISSUE TO
HELP IT SHOULD BE IMPACT THE
LITTLE LUCIEN PATTED BACK ARE
REDUCTION FOR THE OF JUNE.
FORTY THREE. I HAVE BEEN TWENTY
YEARS AS A FOR MY- HAVE ON BEEN
A LONG WITH THE HOW SAFETY OF
MIKE. WHAT MY OWN BODY STRUGGLE
THE BEFORE I CAME UNDER THAT
ARE RELYING ON LOS SOUTH OF
CRIMINAL. FOR WAR ON DRUGS. IT
ACTUALLY FUELING OUR BECAUSE
CRISIS. BY FOCUSING ON TWENTY.
LARA THE REAR THAT USE THE
HEALTH ISSUES. A CRIMINAL. I
GOT A SPENT TIME ENCOURAGED HE
ALSO TRIED TO ACTIVATE HE GOT
THE HELP HE IN DESERVED. I AM
SO SORRY AND I SHARE THE PAIN
OFEVERY FAN MEMBER WAS MY
THEIR FORM. I FEEL ANGRY. THE
AFTER LOSING BROTHER IS WHILE I
DESPERATE WANTED THE BLANKS
FROM MY BROTHER'S DEATH BUT I
KNEW THAT SPENDING THE WHO ME
THE TO PRESIDENT WASN'T BRING
IN. TO THE BLUE BOTH LIBERAL
NUMBER FOR OF. I CHIU TO PLACE
BLAME ON TO THAT ENDANGER OUR
HELP SAFETY. H. B. THREE FIFTY
ONE ALL PEOPLE HAD NO TO IN
EFFECT JUST. ONE AND AGAIN MY
CONDOLENCES TO EVERYTHING
MEMBER HERE IF BOB. THEM
TREMENDOUS PAIN THAT MIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK IS
REPRESENTING. GOOD POLICY
ALLIANCE A NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION IN
OPPOSITION. HELLO SADNESS FOR
THOSE OF US WHO LOST LOVED ONES
AND CLOSE FRIENDS THE DRUG
OVERDOSE. THE CRISES OF
WIDESPREAD DRUG MISUSE AND- THE
HIGH RATES OF DRUG OVERDOSE OR
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES. AND THE
STATED INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS TO PUT PEOPLE
WHO SELL DRUGS IN PRISON FOR
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME. THE
PARTY MORE PEOPLE IN PRISON FOR
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME WILL NOT
AMELIORATE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISES. THIS IS A DRUG WAR HAS
ALREADY PROVEN THAT. UNITE
STATES AND CAL WE PURSUED A
POLICY OF. BUYING A MILLION
THAT ARE CITIZENS INTERNET
SURFACED THE USE OF DRUGS.
RESULT IS ON THE HORIZON CAR.
RATES WERE. AND DRUGS AND ORE
Y. BASED. CHEAPER MORE DEADLY
THAN ANY TIME IN OUR- THE DRUG
WORLD TAUGHT US THAT LAWS LIKE
THESE. IT SHOULD BE TO RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN CARSON. BLOG MAY
LOOK GRAYSON ON THEIR BUT DUE
TO PATTERNS OF CHARGING
SENTENCING THEY ALWAYS ALMOST
ON BOTH LAB MIX INDIGENOUS
ENDED THE FAMILIES AND. TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MATTER. IT IS
LIKELY THIS BILL WILL A PROBLEM
OF OVERDOSE WORSE NOT. SURVEYS
WITNESSES TO DRUG OVER AND-
SAID OVER AND OVER THAT THE
FEAR OF POLICE IMPROPER. IS THE
NUMBER ONE RE. WHY THEY DON'T-CALL NINE ONE OR A FRIEND TO
THE E. R. LASTLY. PROBABLY
DOLLARS ARE NOT ONLY THERE ARE
BETTER AND GOT TO SAY LIFE.
ROXETTE CAPRICOR OF ONE YOUR
ACCOUNT PRISON IS NOW HOW AND
HOURS DOLLARS PER YEAR. BUT A
LOT OF MONEY WE CAN SEND AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY PEOPLE TO
METHADONE TREATMENT FOR A YEAR
ARE NOT. PEOPLE DEEPEN OUR
TREAT. FOR PEOPLE IN TREATMENT
WILL SAY LIVES PEOPLE AND WILL.
THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR. WE
SHOULD STOP SPENDING ON AND IN
CAR. POLICIES AND INVESTMENT
FOR. AND HARM REDUCTION HOUSING
AND HEALTH CARE. IN ORDER TO
PRESERVE TEMPERATURE LIFE.
THANK YOU. WE'RE TRY ONCE AGAIN
GOING TO GO TO THIS AGAIN IT
MAKES I NOT MISSING ONE FOR TWO
WILL AND OPPOSITE. SENIOR AND
TWENTY FOUR. AND OPPOSITE ABOUT
THREE FIFTY. CENA NOW MY- WE
WILL GO THE PHONE LINES FOR
THOSE IN Q. WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION SB. THREE FIFTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
AGAIN WE DO CERTAINLY ONE TO
STRAY. THAT THIS IS FOR THE WHO
ARE STE AND OPPOSITE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE. ONE
SEVENTY THREE. HI MY NAME IS
JESSICA SMITH AND THE COMMUNITY
MOBILIZATION COORDINATOR WITH
NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION I ALSO FORMERLY RAN A
TURN FOR THE PROGRAM AND WILL
NOT. YEAH I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK THREE FOR
LAWS LIKE THIS NOT ORG. THEY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN. SHE
LEVELED PEOPLE WHO. WHAT COLOR
THANK YOU. BY. TWO OH ONE. I'M
IN A IS JOHN I HATE I'M OF
OPIATE IN USER I WORK WITH THAT
HIGH REDUCTION- WE NEED A
BETTER AND AS SB THREE FIFTY IS
NOT THE FULL TO THE OVERDOSE
CRISIS I'M IN STRONG WITH. PINE
ONE SEVENTY SIX. HI MY KANNAN
O'NEILL AND I NEED HELP
DIRECTOR AT ATIONAL CRIMINAL
COALITION I AM CALL IN OFTEN SB
FIFTY I'VE UNLOCKED MANY FRIEND
AND I. D. CAN'T WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING ADDRESS THE PARENTAL
DEATHS BUT INTERNET- NO AT THAT
HARSHER REDUCED THAT ARE YOU
DRUGS PLEASE UPLOAD BACKBEAT.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE. THREE OH
SEVEN. SB THREE OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES HELLO. I'M BY MY
NAME IS LINDA CAMPBELL AM- THAT.
THREE UP. IN HONOR OF THE
MEDICAID CALM- FROM THE. FIND
OH NINE. I NAME IS A RENEWAL
MEREDITH. FOR THREE TWO NINE PM
FOUR ORDER I HAD A LOT COUSIN
WHO- DEEP BETTER AND I THINK WE
NEED. FOR THANK YOU- FIND ONE
SEVEN RIGHT MODERATOR WERE
LOOKING FOR WHEN THIS IS AN
AWFUL TO THIS. YES AGAIN. WE
ALSO ARE IN OPPOSITION. AND FOR
THE SAME REASONS AS MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN OPPOSITION UNTIL
THIS IS A PERPETUATING THE ROLE
OF THE WAR ON DRUGS AND THIS IS
NOT THE WAY TO HAVE SOME OF THE
SENTINEL PROBLEM MA'AM ASSEMBLY
ARE SINCERELY SORRY TO ALL THE
VICTIMS SO. NINE ONE NINETY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER CURVEBALL I'M A
DOCTORAL STUDENT AT THE U. FEEL
THE FIELDING SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB THREE FIFTY WE NEED EVIDENCE
BASED SOLUTIONS BACKED BY
RESEARCH AND PUBLIC HEALTH THIS
IS STRONGLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE.
AS WE BELIEVE. NINE TWENTY.
DANIEL GOOD TERRACE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
BY. NINETEEN HI THIS IS A
CLASSIC VANDER HOOP ON THE
SIDEWALK PROJECT. MY
ORGANIZATION IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AT THREE FIFTY
BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT WE DO
YEAR DIRECTLY ON THE STREET AT
THE FRONT LINES OF THE OVERDOSE
CRISIS. ANOTHER FORMER OPIATE
USER AND I'VE LOST A LOVED ONE.
ANTIC PARTNERSHIP APPEAR OVER.
NO IMPAIR IN THAT. BLIND.
EIGHTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS OPEN
YES HELLO MY NAME IS RAFAEL
AMERICA AND CALLING
REPRESENTING INLAND EMPIRE HARM
REDUCTION WITH THEIR DRUG USERS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY I'M ALSO
CALLING PEAKING ON THE TOPIC
THAT WE BY HI WHO LOST HER
HILLARY CAN. TO FROM ALL OVER
GOES ON JUNE TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWO WE ARE STRONG ENOUGH AT
THAT THREE FOR THANK YOU. WHY
THIRTEEN. ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THREE
THIRTEEN POINT THREE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS HATCHER RANTS I WORK AT THE
NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION. FOR USE IN
COMBINATION AND AT THE FOR DRUG
THE QUIET WILL STABILIZE NOT
COLLIDING AND STIGMATIZING
THOSE IMPACTED BY DRUG USE.
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE FIFTY
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
NUMBER. ONE LIVE. ONE SIXTY.
FIND CREATE CLEAN. CANACCORD
ARE NOT ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION. NINE
THREE OH TWO. I. ONE THIRTY.
YES THANK YOU THIS IS DEREK
BUYERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENDERS ARE SO SCARY AND WE
ARE CLOSED R. S. B. OPPOSE SB
THREE FIFTY THANK. ONE THREE
TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR YEAR ONE IS OPEN.
MOVADO. ONE THREE TWENTY FIVE.
IN OPPOSITION SB THREE FIFTY
THANK YOU. PARTY LINE PRIEST
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LAWN WAS NOT
HEARD GO AHEAD REPEAT PLEASE.
HI I'M DANNIELLE A WALKIE I AM
A RESIDENT OF BERKELEY AND I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION SB THREE
FIFTY AND I GUESS WHERE DOES
THANK YOU. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. MODERATOR I WOULD
JUST ASK ME WHEN THEY HAVE. THE
WINDS ONE MORE TIME FOR THOSE
IN OPPOSITION SB THREE FIFTY
ONE MORE TIME. FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BY TWO
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MOVE ON COMBINED. ONE
NINETY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING TO
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DURING MY BIRD ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND MEDIA
OUTLETS WHICH DOES NOT
CALIFORNIA IF THE OPPOSITION AT
THREE FIFTY. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES OKAY HI I'M
SHANNON KNOCKED THEM THE
DIRECTOR OF TRAINING ASIAN
EQUITY HEALTH PROJECT LOS
ANGELES AND I ALSO OVERSEE
OVERDOSE EDUCATION AND NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION WITH THE COUNTY- I
AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF WHAT
HAD THAT BRIEF MAKE BUT INSTEAD.
AND I WOULD ECHO A- WHO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSIONS- AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MATTER ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR-
CONCERNS. FROM ANY MEMBER ON
THIS BILL. SOONER OR TROUBLE.
TO- THIS IS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. ON THIS
MATTER AND- I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD- I'M A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE- FOR THIS IMPORTANT
BILL THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT
FORTH AND TO. WHO TO THE
PARENTS HERE PRESENT THE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES. ACCIDENTALLY THROUGH THE
OVERDOSE OF THE FENTON ALL-
WHERE DOES I A MY SINCERE
SINCERE CONDOLENCES- JUST AN
OBSERVATION I NOTICED MANY OF
YOU FOLKS MENTIONED THE AGE OF
YOUR CHILDREN. AND IT JUST SO
HAPPENS THAT MY CHILDREN ARE
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME AGE AS
YOURS. SO I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE
CANNOT IMAGINE- THE SITUATION
THAT YOU'RE IN- THIS ISSUE. THE
FUNDAMENTAL EPIDEMIC HAS BEEN
RAVAGING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION IN RECENT
YEARS. IT HITS HOME AND SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY THREE WHICH IS
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT-
US ON THIS COMMITTEE. THERE
WERE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN FENTANYL RELATED DEATHS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN TWENTY
TWENTY ALONE. AND IN RECENT
MONTHS 50% OF ALL THE OVERDOSE
DEATHS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HAVE BEEN ATTRIBUTED TO
FENTANYL. FENTANYL IS A
SYNTHETIC OPIATE THAT CAN BE
FORMULATED TO BE FIFTY TIMES
MORE POTENT THAN HEROIN. AND
FATAL FENTANYL OVERDOSES OCCUR
IN AMERICA UP OF THOUSANDS OF A
GRAM. OFTENTIMES THE USER OF
THESE TRUCKS HAD NO KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE DRUGS THEY ARE
CONSUMING CONTAIN THIS
DANGEROUS SUBSTANCE AND FAR TOO
MANY HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES AS A
RESULT. THIS CONSTITUTES MORE
THAN NEGLIGENCE ON THE
MANUFACTURER'S BEHALF AND
SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE THE
SERIES OF EVENTS THAT IT IS. SB
THREE FIFTY IS ONCE MET A SMALL
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THIS
EPIDEMIC. IT IS A WARNING JUST
LIKE A WARNING WHEN YOU GET A
D. Y. AND IT LETS THE- PERSON
THAT'S BEEN. CONVICTED OF THE
DIY TO LET THEM KNOW THAT IF
THEY CONTINUE ON THAT PATH.
THAT THEIR ACTIONS WOULD HAVE
SEARS CONTACT CONSEQUENCES
INCLUDING. THE LOSS OF LIFE.
THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
GIVES A WARNING TO THOSE WHO
MANUFACTURE IN THE WHO SELL.
THESE THESE DRUGS TO LET THEM
KNOW THAT IF THEY CONTINUE IN
THAT PRACTICE BUT THEIR ACTIONS
HAVE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
CONSEQUENCES WHICH YOU HEAR. IN
THIS ERA AND IN IN THE CAPITAL
ON THE SO CALLED ARE.
UNFORTUNATE VICTIMS. OF THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE IT IS WITH DATA
UNDERSTANDING. THAT IT IS JUST
A WARNING. JUST THE BEGINNING
STOP. BUT I A WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND REQUEST
FOR YOUR EYEBALL IT AND MOVE IT
WHEN THE TIME COMES
MISAPPROPRIATE THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
BUT OF ALL I WANNA A- I WANT TO
JUST. FIVE ALL OF THE- PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS FRIENDS- WHO CAME
OUT TODAY PHYSICALLY ARE ON THE
PHONE TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
DIRECTOR TRAGEDY- THAT YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED- THAT IS NOT EASY-
THAT IS- IT'S NOT EASY THAT IS.
YEAH I KNOW HAVING EXPERIENCE
AWESOME MY FAMILY. IT IS VERY
HARD TO TALK ABOUT. AND SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT- FIVE ALSO- HI. YESTERDAY
I HAD A ASSUME WITH A GROUP OF.
PARENTS COULD I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO HAVE THAT
DIRECT COMMUNICATION I
APPRECIATE THEM TAKING THE TIME
AND ARE BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
VERY CANDID- AND YOU KNOW
DIFFICULT ON DIALOGUE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE- I'VE ALSO I. READ
EVERY SINGLE EMAIL- THAT I
RECEIVED ON THIS AND I
APPRECIATE ALSO WHOEVER PUT
TOGETHER THE BOOKLET WITH A
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES OF THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR STORIES
AND I REVIEWED THAT COVER TO
COVER AND IT WAS ABSOLUTE
HEARTBREAK IN THIS WHOLE
SITUATION. IS JUST IT'S SUCH A
DEEP TRAGEDY AND IT'S GETTING
WORSE. WE ARE AS I MENTIONED TO
THE GROUP I SPOKE WITH
YESTERDAY IN SAN FRANCISCO LAST
YEAR MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE. DIED OF OVERDOSE DEATHS
LAST YEAR THEY WERE NOT ALL
FEDERAL- BUT A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE WERE. THAT WAS THE
YEAR THAT WAS A RECORD AND
NEARLY DOUBLE THE PREVIOUS
RECORD. SAN FRANCISCO IS ON
TRACK TO BREAK THE RECORD AGAIN
THIS YEAR IF THE FIRST FEW
MONTHS ARE INDICATIVE OF THE
REST OF THE YEAR WHICH I.
SUSPECT THAT TRAGICALLY THEY
WILL BE IN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS. WHETHER THEY
ARE FIFTEEN WHETHER THEY'RE
THIRTY WORTH OF THEIR SIXTY
YEARS OLD THESE ARE ALL. HUMAN
BEINGS THESE ARE OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS OR FRIENDS. OR
NEIGHBORS MAY HAVE. FAMILIES
AND NAY- AND THEIR LIVES
MATTER. AND WE ARE FAILING-
RIGHT NOW AND FEDERAL IS JUST A
IT'S A DESPICABLE SUBSTANCE.
AND IT IS JUST HARMING SO MANY
PEOPLE. BOND IF. THIS BILL. HI
AN INCREASING THE PENALTIES
BECAUSE I IT IS A WARNING BUT
IT'S A WARNING ABOUT THE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO
INCREASE THE POSSIBILITY OF
ULTIMATELY PROSECUTING AND
CONVICTING SOMEONE OF MURDER-
IF THIS WERE AN EFFECTIVE- WAY
OF REDUCING. DRUG USE REDUCING-
DRUG DEALING IT WILL BE
SOMETHING TO TALK ABOUT AND
CONSIDER- BUT I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IT WILL AND THE REASON
THAT I SAY THAT AS WE HAVE.
DONE THIS BEFORE. WE HAVE-
WE'VE GONE THROUGH LONG PERIODS
OF TIME IN THIS COUNTRY. OF
INCARCERATING DRUG DEALERS
INCLUDING LOW LEVEL DRUG
DEALERS. FOR LONG LONG PERIODS
OF TIME DRUG DEALERS WHOSE
DEALING LEAD TO DEATH OR NOT.
PUTTING THEM AWAY FOR YEARS OR
DECADES ARM BANDS. AND THAT ID
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM. IT DID
NOT REDUCE DRUG USE THE NOT
pAND OVERDOSE OR MUCH WORSE NOW
THAN THEY WERE BEFORE. WE
ADOPTED THOSE HARSH PENALTIES.
AND SO YOU KNOW PUTTING MORE
PEOPLE WAY FOR LONG PERIODS OF
TIME IS NOT GOING TO REDUCE THE
SUPPLY OF DRUGS AS LONG AS
THERE IS DEMAND- THE SUPPLIER
WILL BE THERE AND THE DEALERS
WILL BE THERE. AND WE NEED TO.
AND WE NEED WE NEED TO TAKE
BETTER APPROACH. TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS BOB THIS ISSUE- WE
CONTINUE- TO PREVENT HARM
REDUCTION AND TO PROHIBIT. OF
HARM REDUCTION METHODS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVEN- TO ACTUALLY
HELP. IT IS ACTUALLY STILL A
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE
SOMEONE WITH A FRONTAL STRIP SO
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY SWAP AND
TEST THEIR DRUGS TO SEE IF
FEDERAL IS THAT THAT'S A LEGAL
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA. THERE
A LOT OF THEIR A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO. TO SAVE
LIVES I JUST I JUST DON'T THINK
THAT THIS PUTTING HAVING LONGER
SENSES OF PUTTING PEOPLE IN
JAIL FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
IT'S NOT GOING TO PREVENT ANY
OVERDOSES- AND I THINK THAT IS
A FALSE HOPE AND SO I WILL NOT
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'RE
GONNA SHOOT TO RESTRAIN YOUR
COMMENTS REALLY WE RESPECTED
EVERY WHAT THIS YEAR WHAT
WHETHER YOUR POSITION WAS WE
RESPECTED SO. WE EXPECT THE
SAME TO YOU. BYE BYE. OKAY
FINE. IT'S A WHOLE LOT OF
OVERDOSE. US SENATORS PLAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
ASCENDER MELINDA'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY'RE WORSE
NOT UNDERSTANDING OUR SEAT IN
THE ANALYSIS IN IN THE-
MATERIALS THAT THERE WERE SOME
AMENDMENTS OFFERED AND- EXCEPT
AS FAR AS MY REDID THE
AMENDMENTS THAT IF THEY WERE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL THE BILL
WOULD DO WHAT YOU DESCRIBED
WHICH IS GIVE A WARNING. AND
THAT THE BILL WITHOUT THOSE
AMENDMENTS DOES MORE THAN JUST
THE WARNING IT ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDES A- DIRECTION IN FACT
THAT- MIGHT SUBSTANTIATE- AN
ADDITIONAL RATHER READ A
JUSTIFICATION FOR-
PROSECUTORIAL ACTION NO I
APPRECIATE THAT THE THAT YOU'RE
THAT THE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL
WOULD LIKE TO. SEE THAT
POTENTIALLY HOWEVER I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR IN IN ANY-
COURT CASE FOR MOTIVESAND SUCH
TO BE DETERMINED IN THE PROCESS
OF THE DETERMINATION IN- IN THE
COURT HEARING AND IF WE COMPARE
THIS TO FOR EXAMPLE THE D. Y.
WARNINGS THEY DO NOT HAVE A
THEY DO NOT HAVE THAT ELEMENT
AND SO- I WONDER IF YOU WOULD
TAKE THOSE AMENDMENT THE
AMENDMENT BECAUSE I COULD
SUPPORT THE BILL. WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- THANK
YOU SENATORS AND WHAT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THERE
STILL IS THE WARNING JUST
WANTED TO BE CLEAR ON THE
RECORD BUT GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER SAID THE
AMENDMENT THAT WAS OFFERED BY
THE COMMITTEE WAS TO- REMOVE
THE IMPLIED MALICE FROM THE
BILL AND JUST HAVE THE
ADVISEMENT READ- TO THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR. COULD CAUSE THE ROOT
DO NOT RESULT IN THE DEATH OF
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING SO IT
REALLY TOOK. THE GUTS OF THE
BILL AWAY BECAUSE AT THIS POINT
IN TIME WHEN SOMEONE IS BEFORE
COURT BEFORE JUDGE. IT IS
INEVITABLE THAT THE JUDGE IS
GOING TO INDICATE TO THAT
PERSON IT THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR
YOU'RE ENGAGING IN. IS HARMFUL
IT'S GOING TO HURT SOMEONE
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE THERE
BEFORE THE JUDGE SO TELLING THE
JUDGE TO. COMMUNICATE THAT TO
THE PERSON. IT DIDN'T IT
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE THE IMPLIED MALICE IN
THE BILL AS A WARNING AS AN
ADVISEMENT AND I JUST WANT TO
STRESS THAT- IT'S NOT A
GUARANTEE. THAT SOMEONE WOULD
BE CHARGED WITH THE MURDER.
IT'S AN OPTION IT'S NOT
MANDATORY SOME DA'S MAY NOT
CHOOSE TO GO THAT ROUTE. OTHERS
MAY FIND CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH
THEY FIND THAT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE IT'S NOT DESIGNED
FOR LIBERAL USE IT'S DESIGNED
FOR VERY JUDICIOUS USE BUT FOR.
ME TO REMOVE THE PART OF THE
BILL THAT IS THE HEART OF THE
BILL WHICH IS THE ABILITY- TO
USING IMPLIED MALICE I COULD
NOT AGREE TO REMOVING THAT FROM
THE BILL AND ONLY HAVE A BILL
THAT SAYS. THE JUDGE SHOULD
READ TO THE DEFENDANT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS DANGEROUS I
THINK. THEY'RE ALREADY DOING
THAT SELL TIME AND FORTUNE I
COULD NOT- EXCEPT THAT
AMENDMENT IN YOUR CLOTHES. YOU
MADE MORE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE
WILL IN FIVE MINUTES. IN YOUR
CLOTHES YOU THE- TO THE MORNING
THAT IS GIVEN IN THE DRIVING K.
AND WOOD AT THE DRUNK DRIVING
CASE DO NOT INCLUDE THAT MALICE.
AND SO YOU USE THAT A- AND
WHICH- IS ANALOGY THAT I. AGREE
AND I WOULD ACCOMPLISH MUCH OF
WHICH YOU ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
ESPECIALLY IF WE ARE USING. IF
WE ARE MAKING THAT COMPARISON-
HOWEVER THAT A DECISION WHICH
YOU NOW SAY MAKES YOUR BILL NOT
USEFUL THEN YOU CAN'T REALLY
MAKE IT AND YOUR- THE ANALOGY
TOWARDS WHAT WE HAVE ALLOWED.
IN STATUTE ON DRUNK DRIVING. SO
I THINK I- AGAIN I THINK THAT.
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION
IS REASONABLE AND AS YOU KNOW.
ALL OF OUR BILLS THE WHOLE
POINT OF THE COMMITTEE PROCESS
AND OF OUR COMMITTEES
CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE. MANY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN IN WHAT
IT WHATEVER THE FIELD IS THAT
IS OF THE COMMITTEE'S CONCERN
IN IN THIS CASE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY WE HAVE CONSULTANTS WHO
HAVE- PART NOT ONLY EXTREMELY
FAMILIAR WITH ALL OF CALIFORNIA
STATUTES BUT ALSO JUDICIAL
PROCESS HE'S PROSECUTORIAL
PROCESS HE'S IN OTHERS. AND I
THINK THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
HAVE VALUE AND I CANNOT SPEAK
FOR MY OTHER COLLEAGUES BUT I
HAVE I SUSPECT THAT THIS BILL
WOULD. BE SUCCESSFUL IF THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN MOST OF US DON'T EXPECT
TO EVER HAVE ANY OF OUR BILLS
FLY THROUGH WITHOUT SOME LEVEL
OF AMENDMENT. SENATOR SKINNER I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
AND I HAVE MADE NUMEROUS
COMPROMISES ON BILLS THAT I'VE
RIGHT BEFORE THE SENATE AND FOR
THE ASSEMBLY WE ALL HAVE TO DO
IT. KNOWING GETS THEIR BILL
THROUGH GENERALLY ON THE FIRST
PASS WHAT THE COMMITTEE ASKED
ME TO DO THOUGH ESSENTIALLY WAS
TO TURN IN A BILL THAT SAYS A
JUDGE NEEDS TO ADVISE SOMEONE
THAT THEIR BEHAVIOR THEY'RE
ENGAGING IN. COULD KILL ANOTHER
HUMAN BEING THAT'S IT WE DON'T
NEED A LOT TO DO THAT. A JUDGE
IS ALREADY DOING THAT WHEN THE
WHEN AND DEFENDANT IS IN FRONT
OF THEM TO THE STATUTE THAT YOU
DESCRIBED AS THAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO MAYOR. I'M SORRY SAY
AGAIN THAT IS WHAT IS IN THE
ADVISORY. HUNDRED DO YOU AYE
CASE. SO YOU USED THE ANALOGY
OF YOUR INTENTION TO PUT INTO
STATUTE THAT WHICH WE DO IN DO
YOU AYE CASES. THAT'S
INCORRECT. THE BILL THAT'S
THAT'S JUST NOT CORRECT IN
NIGHT I'M SORRY IF IT EITHER
SOME MISUNDERSTANDING IN IN THE
U. DISPOSSESSED DISCUSSIONS YOU
HAVE HAD ABOUT THIS BILL BUT
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT CORRECT IT IS
DESIGNED TO ALLOW. A PROSECUTOR
ON A SUBSEQUENT INDICTMENT TO
USE THE IMPLIED MALICE IN THE
EVENT THEY WANT TO USE- A
MURDER CHARGE I DON'T HAVE TO
BUT IT'S GIVES THEM THE OPTION
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES
THAT'S PART OF THE ADVISEMENT
WHEN THEY TELL THEM YOU KNOW
YOU COULD BE CHARGED WITH
MURDER IN THIS BOX. THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL DOES. SO ARE YOU. I
DON'T KNOW- I'M NOT SURE YOU
AND I ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO.
RESOLVE THIS IN A FEW MINUTES
WE HAVE LEFT IN THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING BUT I WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT. MY EIGHT MY GOAL IS
NOT TO MAKE IT- YOU KNOW MORE
PUNITIVE THAN NECESSARY OR MORE
PUNITIVE PERHAPS IN LIGHT. WE
HAVE ALREADY SET UP FOR DO YOU
AYE CONVICTIONS. HOWEVER IT
DOES SO IT IS NOT ANALOGOUS TO
WHAT WE HAVE LISTED IN THE D.
Y. WELL AND WE HAVE EXISTING
STATUTE. THAT IF THERE IS IN
FACT PROVEN TO BE MALICE AND IF
THERE IS KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
WAS FENMORE SORRY YOUR
CONFERENCE WILL END IN ONE. AND
IF THERE IS KNOWLEDGE BY THE
DEALER. THAT THERE WAS FENTANYL
IN THE SUBSTANCES THEY CAN BE
CHARGED WITH. AND THERE AND THE
ANALYSIS CITES THE VERY
STATUTES THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS
THAT ALLOW SUCH. AN I- IS I
INDICATED COULD SUPPORT THE
ADDITION OF THE WARNING AS USED
IN THE CLOSE BUT NOT THE
ADDITIONAL- FREEZING WHICH IS
NOT IN OUR STATUTE REGARDING D.
WEISS AND. SKINNER SKINNER SAYS
SENATOR A COMMON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO- APPLAUD
SENATOR MELENDEZ FOR ORGANIZING
ALL OF THESE FAMILIES- I AM.
AND PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
PACKAGE WHICH I DID READ SO I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU AND YOUR
OFFICE THE CREDIT FOR PUTTING
IT TOGETHER- AND I ALSO WANT TO
SALUTE THE FAMILIES FOR.
SHOWING UP AND FOR CALLING IN.
AND SHARING YOUR STORIES ABOUT
YOUR LOVED ONES WHO WERE LOST
TO THIS DRUG. YOU KNOW I WISH
WE DIDN'T HAVE TO ASK FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS TO RE LIVE- THESE
MOMENTS BECAUSE I AM SURE THAT
IT CANNOT BE EASY FOR YOU TO DO
SO- IN THIS I THINK HAPPENS TO
BE A COMMITTEE WHERE SO OFTEN-
FAMILY MEMBERS FROM ALL SIDES.
ARE ASKED TO RE LIVE- PAINFUL
MOMENTS AND EXPERIENCES AND
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS BILL DOES
OPEN THE DOOR. FOR PROSECUTORS
TO CHARGE- DEALER SELLERS.
HOWEVER THAT IS DEFINED- WITH
MANSLAUGHTER OR MURDER. AND YOU
KNOW ACCIDENTAL DRUG OVERDOSE
AND I BELIEVE THAT MOST
OVERDOSES ARE ACCIDENTAL- IN MY
MIND DOES NOT EQUATE
MANSLAUGHTER OR MURDER. WHAT
DRUG OVERDOSE IT IS NOT
HOWEVER. I'M WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO CONTAIN YOURSELVES IF
YOU CAN YOU'RE GOING TO BE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ASKED TO
LEAVE THE ROOM. WHAT LEAVE THE
ROOM AND LEAVE IT LEAVE THE
ROOM. WHAT DRUG OVERDOSE IT IS
SAD AND UNFORTUNATE AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE.
TALKING ABOUT OPENLY AND
WITHOUT STIGMA. WE OVER
MEDICATE WE SELF DIAGNOSE WE
STIGMATIZE DEPRESSION. CAN WE
DO IT ALL IN THE SILENCE. OF
DARKNESS AND WE COLLECTIVELY
ARE AT FAULT FOR NOT HAVING
MUCH MORE OPEN DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT ALL OF THOSE ISSUES A
NUMBER OF FAMILY MEMBERS ON THE
PHONE WHO SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL SAID BUT NO IS THE
MURDERER. NO IS THE MURDERER.
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE WE
SHOULD I WOULD FULLY SUPPORT US
PUTTING FINAL ON TRIAL. WE
CERTAINLY SHOULD. ABSOLUTELY
1100% AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SAID THAT THE WAR ON
DRUGS HAS NOT BEEN PROVEN TO
WORK. AN EXPENSIVE COUNTER
PRODUCTIVE OVER INCARCERATION
POLICIES ALSO DO NOT WORK HOW
DO WE FIND. THE RIGHTEOUS
MIDDLE. THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE.
AS HARD AS THIS IS TO SAY AND I
HAVE TO REMIND MYSELF OF IT ALL
THE TIME YOU KNOW JUSTICE AND
RETRIBUTION ARE NOT ALWAYS THE
SAME THING AND IT IS NOT IN THE
INTEREST OF POLICY MAKERS TO
CREATE POLICY- THAT DOESN'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
BILL IS NOT GOING TO BRING BACK
LOVED ONES PEOPLE ON THE PHONE
ALSO MENTION THAT IT'S NOT
GOING TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO EXPERIMENT
WITH DRUGS IT'S NOT GOING TO
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO GET DRUGS. THAT ARE
UNREGULATED. IT DOESN'T ADDRESS
ANY OF THAT. AND WHEN WE ARE
PURCHASING DRUGS OFF THE MARKET
THERE IS RISK WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THAT AS WELL THIS
BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS THE ISSUES
ABOUT THE DISTRIBUTION CHAIN.
IF SOMEONE IS SELLING AND THEN
THERE ARE NO LONGER SELLING
MAYBE THEY'VE HAD A COME TO
JESUS MOMENT THEY'VE THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THIS THEY STOPPED
DOING IT FOR A VERY LONG TIME
WITH THEIR PRODUCT HAPPENS TO
BE ON THE MARKET OR SOMEONE
THEN TAKES THAT UP AND TARTS
DOING IT. DOESN'T ADDRESS THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE. DOESN'T ADDRESS
IF YOU'RE SELLING AND YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT YOU'RE SELLING.
YOU'VE JUST BEEN CAUGHT UP IN
THIS AND YOU'RE BEING TOLD TO
DO SOMETHING BECAUSE OF SOME
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT. DOESN'T ADDRESS
THE FACT THAT MAYBE YOU'VE GONE
TO THE BLACK MARKET TO BUY AN
UNREGULATED PRODUCT BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO OR YOU
CAN'T PURCHASE A REGULATED PALE.
ALL OF THOSE ARE POLICY ISSUES
THAT SHOULD BE INCLUDED IF
YOU'RE GOING TO ESSENTIALLY
OPEN THE DOOR TO ALLOW SOMEONE
TO BE CHARGED WITH MURDER. IF I
WOULD BE WILLING TO ACCEPT. AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL IF THE
AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WERE ACCEPTED AND-
IF IT COMES UP FOR. ME AND IF
DURING THIS PROCESS THAT IS
STILL AN OPTION I WOULD BE VERY
WILLING TO- SUPPORT THIS BILL
BUT IN ITS CURRENT FORM RIGHT
NOW. UNFORTUNATELY I WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO DO SO. THANK YOU
SUBMIT COME LONGER AND I THINK
WE'VE HEARD FROM. ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I
TO WANT TO COMMEND. SENATOR
MELINDA IS FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FOR BUT- HAS BEEN
ARTICULATED THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES IT'S NOT A SINGLE
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY IN
CALIFORNIA PRIOR CROSSES
NATION. WHO DOESN'T SYMPATHIZE
AND EMPATHIZE. TO PUT FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO'VE LOST SOMEONE WHO
FRIENDS TO DRUG OVERDOSE WE ALL
LOVE SOMEONE. WHO HAS LOST A
LOVED ONE WE'VE PROBABLY PURSUE
HAVE LOST A LOVED ONE. FROM
DRUG OVERDOSE HAVE- BUT WHAT IS
MISSING HERE ADDS I THINK SOME
OF THE SENATORS HAVE TRIED TO
ARTICULATE- THERE IS A LEVEL
OF. CULPABILITY. FROM THE USER.
AND THE- N. N. AND YEAH AND.
AND AND WHAT WE NEED TO UNDER.
THE IS ABOUT DRUGS WHETHER IT'S
ILLEGAL STREET DRUGS. OR
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS PRESCRIBED
TO A USER OF BY BATCH I SHOULD
SAY THAT'S NOT PRESCRIBED BY A
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL THERE'S
INHERENT RISK IN DOING SO EVEN
FROM LEGAL DRUGS WE HAVE PLENTY
OF EXAMPLES OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE PRESCRIBED DRUGS AND THEIR
KID OR THEIR NEIGHBOR SOMEONE
GETS INTO THEIR MEDICAL CAMERA
TAKES THOSE DRUGS ANY DIABLES.
THANK YOU SAYS WELL SO WE HAVE
PLENTY EXAMPLES OF. PEOPLE
USING LEGAL DRUGS AND
OVERDOSING SO WE OFFERED UP
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL THAT I
THINK WOULD SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE TO THE TO YOUR- THESE
DRUG RELATED FATALITIES WE HAVE
AN I'M COMMITTED TO DOING THAT
HOWEVER PROVIDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH YET ANOTHER
TOOL TO- GET LONGER SENTENCES
WE NOW HISTORY HAS SHOWN. THAT
DOES NOT TO TEAR DRUG SALES IT
DOESN'T DETER CRIME WHATSOEVER
ALL WE DO IS INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN AS I THINK THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO
STATED. IT'S A SUPPLY DEMAND SO
YOU LOCK SOMEONE UP FOR FIFTY
YEARS IT'S GOING TO BE SOMEONE
QUICKLY THAT VERY NEXT DAY THE
TAKE THAT PLACE AND CONTINUE TO
SELL. THESE DRUGS. SO THESE
POLICY ONLY EXACERBATE- THE
DISPARITIES AS WE STATED AS-
REYES HAZARD RELATES TO OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO WE
KNOW. ALL THE HARM IN THE WAR
ON DRUGS AND I'M SURE WE ALL
SYMPATHIZE WITH ANYONE WHO HAS
LOST A LOVED ONE. ON THIS I
THINK WE HAVE A MEASURE WE HAVE
AN AMENDMENT THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
ACHIEVE YOUR GOAL AND OBJECTIVE
HERE. INTO QUITE- THIS TO THE
D. U. I. WARNING IT'S CLEAR BUT
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT AS WELL
WITH THE DO YOU WHY DO YOU ARE
YOU WANT SOMEBODY YOU GET
BEHIND THE WHEEL AGAIN IF
SOMEBODY DIED YES YOU CAN BE
CHARGED WITH. MANSLAUGHTER YOU
CAN BE CHARGED WITH MURDER
BECAUSE YOU NORMALLY. DID YOU
GET INTO SOME PERSON THERE BUT
AGAIN THERE'S A LEVEL OF
CULPABILITY. IN SELLING SOMEONE
A LEGAL DRUG IN ME AS A
PURCHASER TAKING IT AND THEN.
HAVING SOME LEVEL OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR BUYING
SOMETHING ILLEGAL SO THEY'RE
TWO DIFFERENT SCENARIOS HERE
SO. ON THAT MEASURE- YOU'RE NOT
WILLING TO TAKE THE MEMORIES
SHOULD TAKE IF YOU ARE WILLING
TO TAKE A MEMBER NOT BE MORE
HAPPY SUPPORTERS MEASURE TODAY
BUT WITHOUT THAT. I TO CANNOT
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
SO I WILL. OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
SKINNER THANK YOU FOR THE CLOSE
THANK YOU CHEER FOR THAT
EXPLANATION BUT I ALSO WANT TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT. I DON'T
WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL WE ARE
TALKING PAST EACH OTHER BECAUSE-
THE- THERE IS IN STATUTE NOW AS
IS DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT IF A PERSON KNOWINGLY
SELLS. ANY OF THESE SUBSTANCES
THAT THE KNOWINGLY. F. SENTINEL.
AND THERE IS THEN A DEATH THERE
ARE. MULTIPLE CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
WHICH THAT PERSON CAN BE
CHARGED WITH MANSLAUGHTER WITH
OTHER CHARGES RELATED TO THE
DEATH OF THE PERSON WHO TOOK
THE SUBSTANCE. AND THOSE ARE ON
THE BOOKS AND THE AND IT CITED
IN THE ANALYSIS. AND THE
WARNING PART EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IF YOU WERE TO TAKE
THEM. REQUIRES THEN THE WARNING
TO SAY WHAT THE POSSIBLE FUTURE
CRIMINAL LIABILITY IS THAT
THERE IS CRIMINAL LIABILITY
UNDER EXISTING LAW. AND YOUR
THE BILL WITHOUT AMENDMENTS
DOESN'T NECESSARILY CREATE A
WHOLE NEW STATUTE FOR NEW
CRIMINAL LIABILITY. IT JUST CAN
CAN. CREATE A CIRCUMSTANCE
ENDED IN WHATEVER THE NEXT
CIRCUMSTANCE IS FOR THE
PROSECUTOR PROSECUTOR TO BE
ABLE TO USE INTENTION AND SO
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO AVOID WE
ARE NOT TRYING TO ELIMINATE ANY
CURRENT STATUTE. THAT WOULD PUT
THE PERSON WHO SOLD IT IN A
CRIMINAL LIABILITY SITUATION
THEY ARE STILL IN THAT
SITUATION. AND IN TERMS OF
SUPPORTING THE AMENDMENTS WE
ARE SUPPORTING YOUR INTENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT A PERSON. DOES
HAVE THAT WARNING AND
UNDERSTANDS THAT THERE IS
CRIMINAL LIABILITY AND
UNDERSTANDS THAT THERE ARE
STATUTES ON THE BOOKS THAT CAN
LEAD TO THEIR CONVICTION. IF
THERE'S A DEATH IN SUCH CASE SO
I JUST WANTED TO FOR THE RECORD
BECAUSE I FEEL THAT THOSE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO'VE COME HERE
IN SUPPORT. THAT THE BILL
FERMENTED STILL GIVES A GREAT
DEAL OF IT ACHIEVES MUCH OF
WHAT THE INTENT IS. SO I JUST
WANTED TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE JUST TALKING OVER EACH
OTHER. BAKER MELINDA'S. YES MY
CLOSE KNIT FLITS THANK YOU
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME TAKING THE
TIME TO LISTEN DAHLE OTHERS WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL WASN'T
CRAFTED OUT OF THIN AIR I
DIDN'T JUST COME UP WITH THIS-
JUST OUT OF THE BLUE AT NIGHT
THIS BILL. THE WAY IT IS
WRITTEN DAY WAS CRAFTED WITH
THE HELP OF DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
HE SAID THIS IS THE WAY IN
WHICH THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE
WORDED SO THAT WE CAN DO WHAT
WE NEED TO DO INORDER TO GET
THESE DRUG DEALERS OFF THE
STREET THAT IS WHY IT IS WORDED
THE WAY IT IS SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THAT- IMPLIED MALICE. IS NOT.
EIGHT IT'S NOT- IT'S NOT A NEW
IDEA OKAY HI MALICE IN DRUG
RELATED DEATHS IS NOT A NEW
IDEA TWENTY STATES. NOW HAVE
DRUG INDUCED HOMICIDE LAWS
SECURING THE SAME SENTENCES AS
MURDER AND MANSLAUGHTER IN
THERE ARE MORE STATES THAT ARE
CONSIDERING IT. I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CLAIMS THAT
THE OPPOSITION MADE- THIS IS
NOT A MANDATORY MURDER CHARGE.
THIS IS AN ADVISEMENT A WARNING
YOU GET A SECOND CHANCE THE
NEXT TIME. IF YOU CONTINUE THIS
BEHAVIOR IN YOUR BEHAVIOR
CAUSES SOMEONE TO DIE YOU COULD
BE CHARGED WITH THE MURDER IT'S
NOT AUTOMATIC AGAIN IT DEPENDS
ON THE D. A. IT IS TO BE USED
WITH DISCRETION JUST LIKE IT
IS. WHAT DO YOU AYE CASES. IT
IS NOT DESIGNED TO BE USED
EVERY TIME WE HAVE SOMEBODY IN
FRONT OF YOU AND WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT. THE FRIEND WHO
GIVES SOMEONE A PILL THE LOW
LEVEL DEALER WE'RE TALKING
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WANT TO GO
AFTER THE BIG GUYS OKAY. THE
MASS DISTRIBUTORS THAT'S WHO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT GOING AFTER EVERY
TINY LITTLE LOW LEVEL DRUG
DEALERS THAT IS NOT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL. THERE WAS A
WITNESS WHO TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION THAT MADE THE CLAIM
THAT MORE PEOPLE WOULD IT NOW-
REFUSED TO CALL NINE ONE ONE IN
THE EVENT THAT SOMEBODY WAS
HAVING AN ISSUE. AT WHAT THAT
IS A RIDICULOUS CLAIM THAT IT
WE HAVE GOOD SAMARITAN LAWS FOR
LOTS OF THINGS IN CALIFORNIA OF
SOMEONE. I MEAN IF SOMEONE GETS
IN A CAR ACCIDENT ARE THEY
GONNA NOW SAY- I'M NOT GOING TO
CALL NINE ONE ONE BECAUSE MAYBE
THEY'LL BLAME ME FOR THE CART
THAT'S RIDICULOUS THAT IS
ABSURD ON ITS FACE AND BY THE
WAY. THE GOOD SAMARITAN LAWS
ARE IN PLACE FOR EXACTLY THIS
TYPE OF REASON SO THAT SOMEONE
CAN MAKE THE PHONE CALL THE
SAME SOMEONE'S LIFE AND NO
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
CHARGED. SAID THAT'S JUST.
THAT'S JUST FLAT OUT FALSE. M.
DRUG DEALERS DO YOU HAVE A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE THOUGH TO
PACK FENTANYL INTO THESE PILLS
DESIGNED TO LOOK LIKE
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION.
THEY'RE PUTTING THEM IN
PERCOCET THEY'RE PUTTING THEM
AN OXY THEY'RE PUTTING THEM IN
ADDERALL OKAY THIS GOES DOWN TO
MIDDLE SCHOOL. FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD KIDS WERE TALKING FOURTEEN
YOUR KIDS AND YOU GET ON
SNAPCHAT AND YOU CAN ORDER IT I
MEAN COME ON. COME ON. THEY DO
IT BECAUSE IT'S FINANCIALLY
ADVANTAGEOUS WE ALL KNOW THAT.
THE POSSIBILITY OF POSSIBLY
BEING CHARGED WITH MURDER FOR
ENGAGING IN THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVITY. THAT MIGHT BE PERHAPS
ENOUGH INCENTIVE TO GET AT
LEAST SOME OF THEM I'D OF
DEALING DRUGS THAT ARE LACED
WITH WITH FENNEL I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT THIS IS THE
ANSWER I KNOW IT'S NOT AND YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD LENGTHY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE NEED MORE- SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ADDICTION. AND
I HAVE VOTED FOR BILLS THAT DO
JUST THAT I HAVE DONE THAT I
RECOGNIZE THAT. THE ANSWER
ISN'T TO ALWAYS THROW SOMEONE
IN PRISON BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN
ADDICTION. THE BETTER ANSWER
IS. TO GET THEIR LIFE BACK ON
TRACK I RECOGNIZE THAT AND I'VE
AGREED WITH ALL OF YOU ON THAT
AND I VOTED FOR THOSE TYPES. OF
BILLS BUT THIS HAS TO BE A
PARTNERSHIP. THE ENFORCING AND
REHABILITATION SERVICES IT'S
NOT JUST ONE TOOL IN THE TOOL.
AND JUST ONE BIG. THERE ARE A
LOT OF WAYS THAT WE CAN SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM WEEK. WE CAN HELP.
IT WE CAN'T HELP EVERYONE WITH
WITH THE SAME TOOLS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE ADDICTED TO
DRUGS THAT IS SEPARATE FROM THE
CASUAL USER THAT'S SEPARATE
FROM THE FOURTEEN YEAR OLD IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL HIS FRIEND TELLS
THEM- YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT FINALS
COMING UP AND I TOOK THIS
LIFESAVING REALLY HELP ME FOCUS
AND STAY AWAKE HERE TAKE THIS
OUT OF ROLAND AND THE FOURTEEN
OR TAKES IT AND HE GETS THE ONE
WITH FEDERAL AND IT. THAT
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD DOESN'T NEED
TO GO TO REHABILITATION HE
DOESN'T HAVE A DRUG PROBLEM HE
TOOK AT ONE TIME. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS IS
IT'S A COMPLEX PROBLEM
ABSOLUTELY BUT I JUST. I FEEL
LIKE IT'S IT WAS A NARROW VIEW
TODAY OF HOW WE TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. I HOPE THAT YOU ALL
DID HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK
THROUGH THIS BOOK I KNOW
SENATOR WIENER YOU SAID I
BELIEVE IT IS YOU SAID YOU HAD
A CHANCE TO LOOK THERE I HOPE
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK
THROUGH IT- BECAUSE- AGAIN. THE
IT'S JUST IT DOESN'T KNOW ANY
RACIAL BOUNDARIES IT DOESN'T NO
AGE LIMIT NOTHING. BUT ONE PILL
A PILL IN SOME CASES. AND
THAT'S IT YOU DON'T WAKE UP.
I
KNOW WE WERE DIRECTORS HEARING
UP- SO I WILL JUST SAY. THEN I
AM THANKFUL TO THE PEOPLE WHO
CAME TO TESTIFY TODAY- I KNOW
IT'S HARD. BUT YOU THINK ABOUT
THE THINGS THEY SAID I WANT YOU
TO THINK ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT I'VE SAID
AND I KNOW SOME OF YOU HAVE
EXPRESSED. RESERVATIONS ABOUT
THIS BILL- BUT I AM ASKING YOU
I AM BEGGING YOU ON BEHALF OF
EVERYBODY WHO TESTIFIED TODAY
AND THE PEOPLE. WE'RE GOING TO
GO THROUGH THIS TOMORROW OR BY
THE END OF THE DAY TODAY WHEN
THEY GO TO BED TONIGHT. UNLESS
PERSON THEIR FAMILY FROM NâNG
I'M ASKING YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THAT AND I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE SENATOR MELENDEZ FOR YOUR-
PRESENTATION HERE TODAY ON SB
THREE FIFTY I KNOW WHICH- FOR
THE- PRISON YOU FOR ALL OF US
IN AGAIN WANT TO THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES TO COME. BEFORE
SEDATED TESTIFIED SUPPORT AS
WELL AS IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE
A- MOTION- FROM SENATOR WENT TO
A BOWL GOOD TO SEE. TO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB THREE
FIFTY TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD. A TURBO I BROUGH GUY
COM AUGER. SKINNER WIENER
WIENER NOW DEVOTES. ONE TO ONE.
ONE ONE THE MEASURE BILLS WILL
BE GRANTED RECONSIDERATION OF
THE AUTHOR CHOOSES. WE HAVE A
COUPLE THINGS ON CALL IT WAS-
CAN WE LIFT THE CALL FIRST ON
CONSENT ITEM- CONSULTA. A
CONSENT CALENDAR COMMAGER
CAMARADERIE THE TOP FIVE ZERO.
IT MEASURES OUT CONSENT DOLLARS
OUT FIVE ZERO NEXUS S. B. TWO
SIX TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
CAN YOU LOOK CALL FOR UP TO
MEMBERS. KAMLAGER KAMLAGER AYE
WIENER. HERTZBERG FOR GUY- FOR
ONE OF THAT MEASURES OUT FOUR
TO ONE HUNDRED MEMBERS DUE TO
TIME ON THAT'S GOING TO
CONCLUDE OUR HEARING FOR THE
DAY WE HAVE TO MEASURES OUT BE
CARRIED OVER TO NEXT WEEK'S
HEARING I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY AND SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY WE STAND
ADJOURNED.